bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur public sénat débat sans vote du
parlement cet après midi sur l'irak
manuel valls le premier ministre a
justifié devant les députés
l'intervention française en irak en
soulignant que la sécurité nationale de
la france est en jeu comme elle ne l'a
jamais été au cours de ces dernières
années au sénat c'est jean yves le drian
le ministre de la défense qui est venu
pour expliquer l'engagement de la france
on va tout de suite retrouvé sa verrière
ogec en direct de l'hémicycle bonjour sa
verrière bonjour définir comment le
ministre at il justifié la position du
gouvernement est bien delphine c'est un
jean yves le drian solennelle qui a
repris dans l'hémicycle le discours
prononcé au même moment par manuel valls
à l'assemblée les mots employés sont
forts à la mesure de l'événement le
ministre de la défense rappelle le péril
mortel que représente l'état islamique
dèche à périls qui menacent non
seulement la stabilité mais l'existence
même de l'irak jean yves le drian
rappelle que le gouvernement a agi dans
la légalité internationale en expliquant
que les frappes aériennes sont conduites
dans le cadre d'une coalition avec les
forces armées irakiennes et les alliés
de la france en particulier les états
unis l'objectif est clair affaiblir
laich et restaurer la souveraineté liens
que j'avais vu le drian rappelle
également qu'il n'y aura pas
d'engagement de troupes au sol sur la
durée de l'opération autre question
importante
impossible pour le gouvernement d'y
répondre l'opération militaire durera le
temps nécessaire a rappelé le ministre
merci beaucoup savaria alors tout de
suite aux directions l hémicycle
poursuivre ce débat sans vote et on se
retrouve à 19h pour 24 heures sénat le
journal
l'ordre du jour appelle une déclaration
du gouvernement suivie d'un débat sur
l'engagement des forces armées en irak
en application de l'article 35 alinéa 2
de la constitution
la parole est à monsieur le ministre la
défense jean yves le drian
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
un péril mortel
s'étend au moyen-orient
la stabilité de la région et au delà
la sécurité du monde est menacé par le
groupe terroriste dèche
la france est une grande puissance
la france assume ses responsabilités
parce qu'elle est membre permanent du
conseil de sécurité
parce que la sécurité de l'europe est
menacée
parce que notre sécurité nationale est
en jeu
comme elle ne l'a jamais été au cours de
ces dernières années
le président de la république a donc
décidé d'employer la force en irak à la
demande expresse des autorités de bagdad
conformément à l'article 35 de notre
constitution
lorsque les forces armées sont engagés à
l'extérieur le gouvernement informe le
parlement dans les meilleurs délais
le premier ministre a écrit au président
de votre assemblée dès que les premières
frappes ont été réalisés vendredi
dernier 19 septembre
il a reçu ce matin avec bernard
cazeneuve jean marie le guen et moi même
ainsi que le chef d'état-major des
armées et les directeurs des services de
renseignement les présidents des deux
assemblées les présidents des groupes
parlementaires ainsi que les présidents
des commissions de la défense et des
affaires étrangères
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vais exprimer
d'abord
à travers la représentation nationale
tout le soutien de la nation aux
militaires engagés dans l'opération
shamal
le moment est venu à nouveau de faire
corps derrière les armées françaises de
nous rassembler de faire preuve d'unité
et je ne doute pas que ce sera le cas
grâce notamment au travail souvent très
risquée des journalistes
les crimes du groupe death
sont connus de tous
actes de barbarie
massacres de masse
exécutions d'otages
ces terroristes ne connaissent pas de
limites à l'horreur
une horreur qu'ils propagent dans le
monde entier par le biais d'internet
dèche c'est l'acronyme de la terreur
celui d'un groupe qui pèse prétend
établir un califat au coeur du
moyen-orient un groupe qui nov comme
choix que la conversion forcée ou la
mort
lutter contre des ch
c'est combattre une organisation dont
l'appellation
état islamique constitue un double
mensonge
elle n'a rien d'un état et ne représente
en rien l'islam
c'est un rassemblement d'assassins pour
qui la vie humaine est sans valeur
ce groupe comme l'ont exprimé les plus
haute autorité de l'islam est une
insulte à ces deux religions
et c'est une triple menace
une menace pour l'irak une menace pour
le monde est une menace pour la france
c'est d'abord une menace pour l'irak
depuis la chute de mossoul en juin
dernier
des shows constr hall près du tiers du
territoire irakien
il maîtrise les points de communication
et les axes stratégiques
il a accumulé d'immenses richesses lui
permettant de recruter de payer des
supplétifs venus des quatre coins du
monde d'europe et de france
son trésor de guerre a aussi servi à
constituer une vraie armée
près de cent cinquante blindés légers
environ 50 chars de combat des dizaines
de missiles antichars
et ses troupes extrêmement mobiles
pourraient être renforcées par
l'acquisition de nouveaux ariel
aujourd'hui la stabilité de l'irak et
menacé son existence même est en danger
on ira qu'un nouveau gouvernement s'est
mis en place il est maintenant
constituée autour de quelques priorités
lutter contre cet ennemi de l'intérieur
et tenter de réconcilier les communautés
irakiennes sunnites chiites et kurdes
il doit aussi protéger les minorités les
chrétiens d'irak l'eia 6 10
et 7 tensions entre les différentes
communautés qui composent d'irak et
naturellement source d'inquiétude
le système politique irakien doit
trouver un point d'équilibré
tout comme il doit construire dans la
durée avec ses voisins dont l'iran des
relations de confiance
le gouvernement irakien nous appelle à
l'aide
il a demandé le soutien militaire de la
france
c'est notre devoir de l'entendre
aider l'irak
éviter sa désintégration c'est aussi
éviter une déstabilisation massive de la
région nous agissons aussi en conformité
avec la charte des nations unies
car tout état peut demander
souverainement à un autre de lui porter
assistance
c'est aussi une menace pour la région
déchaînés dans le chaos syrien
il a prospéré avec la complicité du
régime de damas et s'est nourri de
l'inaction de la communauté
internationale
ses effectifs serait aujourd'hui proche
de 30 mille combattants
medef ne s'arrêtera pas à l'irak
ses membres qui forment une deuxième
génération de djihadistes après celle
d'al quaida sont au delà de ce pays une
menace pour tout l'orient
ils contrôlent plus du quart du
territoire syrien ils cherchent à
déstabiliser le liban
voilà le vrai plan de cet international
du crime la création d'un sanctuaire
terroriste
allant des rives de la méditerranée
jusqu'à celle du golfe persique
et c'est une menace pour l'europe et
pour la france
j'ai souligné le risque représentent ces
filières y conduisent des individus
français ou résidant en france à
s'enrôler et à partir combattre là bas
vous connaissez les chiffres ils sont
inquiétants c'est aussi pour cela que
nous devons agir
les filières terroristes trouvent dans
ces régions déstabiliser les moyens de
se développer et de frapper les pays
occidentaux
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
nous avons à cet instant tous à l'esprit
le sort de notre compatriote enlevés en
algérie
et c'est à hervé pierre gourdel que
s'adresse mais penser à sa famille à ses
proches
je veux dire aussi aux français que nous
ne laisserons pas intimider
en se prenant à notre compatriote
les djihadistes s'en prennent à nous à
chacun d'entre nous
s'il nous montrons faibles face à cette
menace nous encouragerons hausse et
l'achat poursuivre leur oeuvre de mort
nous ne faillirons pas ne trembleront
pas
face à la menace face au chantage la
france ne cède pas
ce n'est pas notre intervention qui nous
exposent au terrorisme
cette menace est là depuis longtemps et
c'est pour cela que nous agissons et que
nous intervenons
aider l'irak c'est protéger la france
c'est agir pour notre sécurité nationale
depuis plusieurs mois la france a pris
l'initiative
parce que notre pays a toujours été
présent au moyen-orient et parce que
nous avons des responsabilités et des
devoirs envers cette région
nous en comprenons la complexité nous
examinons la situation dans le détail
avec la profondeur historique d'une
vieille nation en évitant le simplisme
et la caricature
début août alors que l'intégrité
territoriale de l'irak étaient mises à
mal que des minorités étaient menacés
que la situation humanitaire se dégrade
est la france a décidé de s'engager
tout d'abord par de l'assistance
humanitaire
puis par la fourniture dames et par la
formation de combattants
se sont désormais nos avions de chasse
qui survole le territoire irakien
d'abord pour des missions reconnaissance
et depuis vendredi dernier pour des
opérations de frappe
les opérations aériennes en cours sont
conduites en plein accord avec des
forces armées irakiennes et en
coordination avec nos alliés en
particulier les états unis et leurs
partenaires arabes
notre objectif est clair
il a été mûrement réfléchie il a été
annoncé par le président de la
république cet objectif je le rappelle
nous répondons à la demande de soutien
des autorités irakiennes pour affaiblir
l'organisation terroriste dash car il
faut aider les forces de sécurité
irakiennes et les combattants kurdes à
restaurer la souveraineté de l'irak
cet engagement militaire se traduit par
des opérations aériennes sur le
territoire irakien nous n'engagerons en
revanche pas de troupes françaises au
sol
nous resterons impliqué le temps
nécessaire
jusqu'à ce que l'armée irakienne
et retrouver la supériorité face à des
shs
n'agissons pas seul
l'action de la france inscrit dans le
cas d'une collation d'une coalition
politique et militaire
cette coalition s'est constitué à paris
lors de la conférence sur la sécurité la
paix en irak qu'à l'initiative du
président de la république le 15
septembre dernier
j'en viens à la syrie
où le régime de bachar el assad continue
de semer le chaos qui profite aux
terroristes
le président de la république l'a
rappelé lors de sa conférence de presse
de jeudi dernier
la france était prête à prendre ses
responsabilités il ya un an
lorsque les preuves d'un usage des armes
chimiques par assad contre son propre
peuple ont été rassemblés nous n'en
serions certaines pompes certainement
pas là en syrie si la communauté
internationale était alors intervenue
les états unis et des des principaux
pays de la région ont décidé de mener
des opérations contre les fiefs de dèche
sur le territoire syrien
pour notre part on fait le choix d'une
concentration l'irak et de continuer à
soutenir l'opposition modérée au régime
de bachar el-assad
ces forces d'opposition lutte avec
détermination contre les terroristes
nous sommes résolus avec nos partenaires
à leur apporter un soutien civil et
militaire accru nos efforts sont
complémentaires en syrie de l'action
militaire que mènent les américains nous
l'avons déjà dit je le répète devant
vous
bachar al assad ne peut absolument pas
être un partenaire dans la lutte contre
des shs
l'action militaire répond à l'urgence
le combat c'est un combat de longue
haleine contre le fanatisme
cette idéologie de mort qui détournent
et qui corrompt le message de l'islam
ce combat ce n'est pas l'occident contre
le moyen-orient et c'était aux pays
arabes aussi ensemble d'agir ils sont
d'ailleurs engagés dans les opérations
mais sans un accompagnement de long
terme sans une réponse diplomatique et
surtout politiques aux causes de la
menace cette action militaire risque
d'être vaine
cette conférence internationale a donc
constitué une étape importante le
ministre des affaires étrangères et du
développement international laurent
fabius l'organisé avec beaucoup ou
d'efficacité elle a permis de dire le
terminer les grandes lignes d'une
stratégie commune elle a démontré la
mobilisation de 29 pays et organisations
internationales pour soutenir les
nouvelles autorités irakiennes engagé
dans la reconstruction de l'état irakien
et la réconciliation du pays autour d'un
gouvernement inclusif
les participants se sont entendus pour
lutter contre la radicalisation pour
améliorer le contrôle des frontières
pour tarir les flux de combattants
étrangers et asséché toutes les sources
de financement de dèche
c'est en effet une stratégie d'ensemble
qui est nécessaire pour combattre ce
terrorisme
l'action militaire n'est qu'un aspect
ainsi au delà de l'engagement militaire
il faut poursuivre les efforts déployés
en matière d'aidé humanitaire
les partenaires de cette conférence s'y
sont engagés la français est en première
ligne nous avons déjà affrété 87 tonnes
dead nous continuerons cette assistance
est tout particulièrement en direction
des minorités dont celle des chrétiens
d'orient
pour stabiliser la région le sort des
populations déplacées doit également
faire l'objet d'une mobilisation
internationale
c'est vrai pour l'irak c'est vrai pour
la journaliste est vrai pour le liban ce
pays ami qui mérite en cet instant notre
solidarité et notre soutien
et face à l'urgence nous accueillons des
réfugiés ayant un lien avec la france et
samedi laurent fabius a ainsi accueilli
à l'aéroport de roissy près de 150
réfugiés irakiens
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
france assume à nouveau ses
responsabilités en agissant pour sa
sécurité ses intérêts et la défense de
ses valeurs
à nouveau en effet car nos armées
restent déployés en afrique sahélo
saharienne au mali au tchad au niger
pour lutter contre le terrorisme dans le
cadre de l'opération barkan
de même nos soldats sont engagés en
république centrafricaine pour aider à
stabiliser ce pays comme nos forces sont
aussi engagés au liban
où elle participe à la sécurisation du
sud du pays est appuyé les forces armées
libanaises
le premier ministre l'a dit hier lors de
son déplacement en allemagne la france
agit lorsque sa sécurité est en jeu mais
elle agit aussi pour l'europe mais
l'europe ne peut pas remettre sa
sécurité à un seul de ses états membres
fussent la france c'est pourquoi nous
n'abandonnons pas notre volonté de voir
progresser une véritable europe de la
défense
tous ces engagements militaires
confirment la nécessité de disposer des
ressources adéquates pour notre défense
et notre sécurité nationale
le président de la république a fait le
choix de maintenir les crédits de la
défense au cours des prochaines années
malgré un contexte budgétaire
particulièrement difficile et nous avons
traduit ce choix dans leur programmation
2014-2019 que vous avez voté l'an
dernier
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
situation en irak et au moyen orient a
aussi des conséquences majeures sur
notre sécurité intérieure
c'est notre principal sujet de
préoccupation sur le plan de la lutte
contre le terrorisme
nous devons agir hors de nos frontières
mais nous devons agir aussi sur le sol
national
parce que les groupes radicaliser
constitue une menace chez nous c'est une
menace inédite qui nécessite un grand
sang froid
et je veux le dire avec force devant
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale
la france fait clairement la distinction
entre l'islam qui est la deuxième
religion de france un atout pour notre
pays et l'islamisme dans son
prolongement terrorisme djihadisme n'ai
qu'un message violent perverti et
contraire aux valeurs universelles de
l'islam
la france doit faire face à un défi sans
précédent vous le savez près de 1000
français aux résidents sont aujourd'hui
concernés par les filières
syro-irakienne
580 d'entre eux combat tout en combattus
là bas 36 y sont morts
189 jadis sont venus de syrie
jamais notre pays n'a eu à affronter un
tel défi en matière de terrorisme
au-delà de ces chiffres
les profils de ces personnes doivent
nous interpeller des mineurs des femmes
des convertis des individus jusque alors
inconnu des services
ils viennent de lieux divers de nos
quartiers de nos territoires et compris
ruraux et aussi l'outre-mer
ces mêmes profils très divers on les
retrouve dans de nombreux pays européens
le d-day le judaïsme violent exerce sur
une jeunesse sans repères une
fascination qui les conduit à la
radicalisation et les mène à l'action
directe le parcours donné mouche
l'assassin du musée juif de bruxelles on
est un terrible exemple
il nous faut être implacables dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme c'est
pourquoi dès décembre 2012 une première
loi antiterroriste à renforcer la lutte
contre le cyber djihadisme a facilité la
répression de l'incitation à la haine et
à la violence terroriste sur internet
elle a aussi prévu la possibilité de
sanctions pénales contre les terroristes
français ou résidents dont l'intégrité
des actes étaient commises à l'étranger
ce travail s'est poursuivi et enrichie
avec le plan de prévention de la
radicalisation présenté en avril dernier
par le ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve et le projet de loi adopté le
18 septembre par l'assemblée nationale à
la quasi unanimité
il va être désormais examinés par votre
autre assemblée
vous en connaissez les quatre objectifs
principaux
prévenir et contrarier les départs mieux
lutter contre la diffusion de la
propagande terroriste notamment sur
internet
prendre en compte le nouveau mode
opératoire des terroristes notamment
ceux qui agissent seuls enfin doter la
justice et les services de police de
moyens d'investigation adapté à la
menace et à ses évolutions
en complément de ces mesures le
gouvernement est engagé dans une
démarche visant à lutter contre les
phénomènes d'endoctrinement et de
radicalisation et accompagner les
familles ils sont confrontés à ce stade
je tiens à rappeler que dans le cadre de
la lutte contre les filières terroristes
vers la syrie cent quatorze individus
ont été interpellés
soixante dix huit ont été mis en examen
et 53 ans était incarcéré au cours des
derniers mois des départs de combattants
y compris deux mineurs ont été empêchés
et plusieurs projets d'attentats sur
notre territoire ont été déjoués
comme vous le savez trois jihadistes
présumés venant de turquie sont arrivés
hier sur le sol national
ils sont maintenant à la disposition de
la police le ministre l'intérieur s'est
exprimé à ce sujet et aura l'occasion
d'y revenir très prochainement mais
cette affaire dois vous le dire ne s'est
pas déroulé comme il l'aurait fallu
je veux rendre un hommage appuyé à
l'ensemble de nos services intérieurs et
extérieurs qui agissent avec courage et
détermination pour protéger nos
compatriotes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
la décision prise par le président de la
république d'engager les forces armées
en irak la demande des autorités
irakiennes repos sur un triple objectif
un objectif de sécurité
car nous sommes confrontés et menaces
directes immédiates et d'une gravité
exceptionnelle un objectif de stabilité
car dahesh met en péril la survie et
l'unité de l'état irakien dans une
région stratégique
un objectif de crédibilité car lorsqu'un
pays ami nous appelle à l'aide quand des
populations innocentes sont massacrés
quand nos partenaires dans la région
sont menacées
quand un groupe terroriste d'une
violence inouïe s'attaque à tout ce à
quoi nous croyons la france ne détourne
pas le regard
ce triple objectif ne peut s'inscrire
que dans une solution politique dans
cette opération militaire n'est qu'un
des volets elle participe d'une
stratégie de long terme
l'action de la france est nécessaire
le président de la république l'a décidé
elle est légitime et conforme au droit
international
elle s'appuiera sur le professionnalisme
le sens du devoir de nos armées elle
doit pouvoir s'appuyer sur le soutien de
la nation toute entière ainsi le
gouvernement souhaite donc pouvoir
compter sur l'appui total de la
représentation nationale
je vous remercie
merci dans la suite du débat la parole
est à présent aux orateurs des groupes
la parole est à pierre laurent pour le
groupe crc
monsieur le président du sénat monsieur
le ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs chers collègues
nous voilà réunis pour débattre de la
participation militaire de la france aux
interventions armées en irak et en syrie
notre débat a lieu six jours après
l'annoncé présidentielle
cinq jours après le déclenchement des
frappes et alors même que ces
préparatifs ont débuté en vérité au
lendemain du sommet de l'otan les 4 et 5
septembre il y a près de 20 jours
j'en viens au faux la première raison
invoquée pour justifier l'intervention
occidentale est la terrible catastrophe
humanitaire à laquelle nous assistons
les jours que vivent les peuples du
proche orient sont effectivement
tragique personne ne peut rester
indifférent devant ce déferlement de
violence et de destruction sur les
populations civiles en plusieurs points
de la région nous avons le devoir de
secourir mais de quelle manière et avec
quelles perspectives c'est en ces termes
que la question se pose en réalité
en trois mois près de 6000 à irakiens
ont perdu la vie depuis janvier 2014 1
million 800 mille personnes ont été
déplacées dans 850 milles qui ont trouvé
refuge au kurdistan irakien syriens ou
turcs sans l'engagement des forces
kurdes elle n'aurait pas eu la vie sauve
au moins 650 mille personnes coincées
dans les zones de combat reste à se
courir la menace ailes d'ange et
s'étendent à la syrie où des shows
reprend l'offensive contre les villes et
villages kurdes dirigés par le pid les
kurdes résiste sol depuis des mois sans
aide internationale
à la fois contre les armées de bachar
el-assad et contre ceux qui se nomment
l'état islamique et les groupes
djihadistes en dépit de l'ouverture de
quelques postes frontières la turquie
multiplie les obstacles à arrivée des
réfugiés et poursuit le blocage de
l'aide humanitaire
singulièrement celui collectées par les
municipalités bdp de turquie la france
elle même n'est pas à la hauteur de
l'aide humanitaire qu'elle peut apporter
au populaire en détresse dans le cas des
réfugiés c'est rien 15 cents ont été
accueillis en france alors que
l'allemagne la suède on en a accueilli
plus de 10000 et pour l'irak moins de
deux cents ressortissants sont ont été
accueillis en deux mois c'est dans ce
contexte que la nos compatriotes vient
de se faire enlever et notre solidarité
évidemment va à hervé pierre gourden et
à ses proches alors qu'il reste
également un otage français aux mains
d'aqmi est dans ce contexte que l'état
islamique menace de s'en prendre sur
notre territoire à la population ces
menaces sont graves elle justifie de
veiller plus encore à la sécurité des
français sur le territoire et à
l'étranger
nous pouvons le faire sans céder à la
peur dans le respect de notre droit et
des libertés grâce au dispositif
législatif et juridique existant nous
considérons que de nouvelles de
nouvelles lois d'exception comme celle
qui vient d'être votée à l'assemblée
sont inutiles et dangereuses
après dix ans d'un fiasco généralisée de
la guerre au terrorisme menée sous
l'impulsion des états unis nous devons
tirer une leçon tant que la lutte contre
les groupes djihadistes ne visera pas
les causes de leur implantation l
objectif ne pourra être atteint
est-ce que des frappes aériennes telles
crises telles que celles qui sont
engagées sont à même de résoudre
définitivement le problème de la montée
en puissance de cette organisation nous
ne le croyons pas car d'où sortent ces
forces obscures les etats-unis et
d'autres dans la région ont joué avec le
feu en en faisant des alliés de
circonstance pour servir leurs intérêts
et se trouve aujourd'hui dépassés par
les monstres qu'ils ont contribué à
créer
ceux qui ont parlé d'un soi-disant choc
des civilisations ou aussi en fait tout
mis en oeuvre pour faire grandir la bête
immonde
n'a vendu que n'avons nous n'avons nous
excuser moi donc rien retenu des
interventions en afghanistan au libye en
libye est déjà en irak en 2003 la lutte
contre le terrorisme
a mobilisé 4000 milliards de dollars
depuis ses débuts et pour quel résultat
d'un foyer de djihadistes nous sommes
passés à 14 alors ayons l'honnêteté
d'avouer que ces interventions ont
toutes été des désastres supplémentaires
enfonçant encore plus les peuples dans
l'humiliation et la misère en renforçant
les capacités de ces groupes la question
n'est pas d'agir ou de ne pas agir bien
entendu il faut agir mais la vraie
question reste comment et avec qui
stoppé la barbarie il faut s'attaquer
aux racines du mal mettre en cause les
états membres ou alliés de l'otan qui
par exemple ont soutenu en armes
matériel et hommes les groupes
djihadistes quand cela les intéressait
il faut mettre en cause ceux qui ces
jours ci continuent d'acheter le pétrole
tiré des puits dans l'état islamique a
pris le contrôle
les frappes aériennes de la france en
irak ont débuté vendredi dernier
avant-hier les frappes américaines ont
touché la syrie tous les experts le
confirment ses frappes aériennes
atteindront très vite leurs limites
quelles sont donc dans ces conditions
les véritables objectifs de guerre c'est
de cela dont il faut débattre les
etats-unis ont annoncé une opération
longue pour une durée d'au moins trois
ans la france compte elle s'engager pour
la même durée et pour quelle suite nous
savons que l'otan n'a pas de solution
politique et que l'otan et sa stratégie
dominatrice font même partie du problème
alors quelle est la stratégie de la
france quelle est sa solution politique
à court et long terme cette solution
politique ne passe-t-elle pas
inévitablement par un dialogue avec
toutes les puissances et tous les pays
de la région la france y at elle renoncé
en s'alignant derrière l'otan quelle est
la marge de manoeuvre est le poids de la
france dans ses décisions en
accompagnant la stratégie de l'otan nous
nous exposons alors que nous n'agissons
plus comme il le faudrait et
suffisamment sur le plan politique que
nous ne soutenons plus avec la
détermination nécessaire les forces de
progrès de la région la tragédie que vit
le peuple irakien est en effet à la
confluence de tous les drames de la
région et tous doivent être attaquer les
conséquences d intervention étrangère
américaine la montée de l'affrontement
sunnite chiite appuyé par des puissances
régionales dont certaines avec lesquels
nous avons des relations étroites le
drame syrien qu'en face à la répression
de bachar el-assad la recherche d'une
solution politique pour une transition
démocratique a été torpillé au profit de
l'engrenage militaire
la question des aspirations nationales
méprisé du peuple palestinien à ce
propos monsieur le ministre j'ai une
question la france apportera tel un
soutien clair et résolu aux nouvelles
propositions de règlement politique du
conflit que le président de l'autorité
palestinienne mahmoud abbas va exposer
lors de l'assemblée générale de l'onu et
qu'il est venu et dont il est venu
parler avec le président de la
république
il y a quelques jours également la
question des aspirations nationales
réprimée du peuple cours kurde
singulièrement par le régime d'erdogan
membres de l'otan notre devoir est de
soutenir les forces kurdes upyd et du
pkk qui sont aujourd'hui en première
ligne allons nous laisser le pkk dans la
liste des organisations terroristes de
l'union européenne
tous ces problèmes se posent évidemment
sur fond de pétrole l'irak possédant les
4e réserves mondiales avec une capacité
de 12 millions de barils/jour
l'invasion et l'occupation américaine
durant 8 ans se sont traduites par une
quasi disparition de l'état irakien la
mise en place de structures politiques
et administratifs sur des critères
religieux et ethniques facteur de
frustration et d'humiliation favorisant
ainsi les tensions communautaires sans
vision nationale commune chacun jouant
pour ses propres intérêts c'est dans ce
contexte que les différents groupes
jihadistes ont pris leur essor les
populations sunnites maltraités ont été
écartés du pouvoir et du partage des
richesses du fait de la politique
sectaire d'al-maliki soutenu tant par
les américains que par les iraniens
l'état central a été démantelée l'armée
privée de cadres et de moyens l'économie
irakienne rendu dépendant exclusivement
du pétrole est contrainte de tout
importer cette fuite en avant a favorisé
la corruption l'enrichissement fulgurant
de quelques-uns le blanchiment de
l'argent des trafics et de la corruption
sur fond de privatisations à outrance
sous les yeux bienveillants du fmi et de
la banque mondiale cette société s'est
peu à peu disloqué créant un terrain
favorable à la montée de la
radicalisation
mais tous ces facteurs n'expliquent pas
à eux seuls l'expansion rapide des
groupes djihadistes armés en effet ces
groupes sont financés équipé au plan
militaire tout ça ne tombe pas du ciel
par des puissances régionales qui les
utilisent de par leur proximité
idéologique au gré de leurs intérêts
soient contrôlés kurdes pour les uns
comme la turquie soit contrôle influence
chiite pour les pays du golfe comme
l'arabie saoudite et le qatar sans ces
soutiens extérieurs plus ou moins
officielles officiels ou non jamais ces
groupes djihadistes n'aurait pu
atteindre la puissance qui est la leur
aujourd'hui au point de menacer
l'existence même de l'irak et de la
syrie allons nous enfin ouvrir le débat
sur les liens étroits que la france
entretient avec certaines de ces
puissances régionales au sein de l'otan
comme la turquie et avec les monarchies
du golfe du golfe comme clients fortunés
de nos ventes d'armes peut-on encore
longtemps fermé les yeux sur ces
réalités
alors
que faire pour combattre ces groupes
jihadistes et leur projet destructeur de
la démocratie et des droits humains
l'irak doit recevoir l'aide nécessaire
ainsi que tout les trucs les troupes
kurdes irakiennes et syrienne pour
combattre les groupes armés mais les
frappes aériennes actuels ne sont pas la
réponse qui permettra de s'attaquer à ce
fléau elles vont perdre chaque jour de
leur efficacité en nourrissant le
ressentiment de populations sunnites
bombardé qui en sont victimes
s'attaquer aux racines du mal
c'est aussi en finir avec le cadre dans
lequel nous multiplions nos
interventions
en accompagnant la prétention d'un petit
nombre d'états occidentaux
s'autoproclamant garant de l'ordre
international
il faut cesser de considérer ces régions
comme l'arrière cour des puissances
occidentales en recherche de débouchés
et de matières premières
l'un des facteurs communs aux guerres
actuelles et aux dangers qui monte et la
prod la prétention maintenu de
l'occident à jouer les gendarmes du
monde alors que les pays concernés
occidentaux ne représente plus que 12 %
de la population mondiale à chaque fois
notre réponse et militaires strictement
militaire alors que ces situations de
violence et de destruction sont le
résultat de très profond déséquilibre
est qu'il faut d'urgence attaquer à ces
déséquilibres en menant des d'autres
politique fondée sur le développement la
coopération et la solidarité avec pour
objectif l'éradication de la pauvreté et
la sécurité dans tous les domaines santé
éducation habitat emploi et lutte contre
les trafics le moyen-orient n'est pas
condamnée à vivre guerre sur hier les
solutions politiques et diplomatiques
peuvent être efficaces car les solutions
les plus efficaces contre la
radicalisation jihadistes sont le
développement la paix la démocratie et
la solidarité
il est grand temps de redonner aux
nations unies la place et le rôle qu'ils
doivent être les siens dans la
prévention des conflits leur résolution
et la mise en oeuvre de programmes de
développement et de partage des
richesses
l'abandon progressif de ceux du seul
cadre multilatéral
reposant sur le droit international et
la souveraineté de toutes les nations de
la planète au profit d'un rôle accru
dans l'otan sous l'égide des états unis
est une des plus grandes erreurs
commises depuis la chute du mur de
berlin la france doit reconstruire sa
vision du monde et cesser de s'accrocher
au wagon de l'otan nous appelons de nos
voeux l'organisation dans cet hémicycle
comme à celui de l'assemblée nationale
d'un départ d'un débat approfondi sur la
politique extérieure de la france
définit hors de la représentation
nationale et des citoyens cette
politique qui est plus atlantiste et que
jamais elle est à contresens de tous que
les évolutions du monde nous appellent à
penser de nouveau sans ce débat notre
politique restera grammaticalement
aveugle et la voix de la france perdra
son sens
merci la parole est à présent à daniel
renner pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
ministre de la défense mes chers
collègues
je vais exprimer l'accord et le soutien
de notre groupe au céda à l'action que
mène le gouvernement en irak
la gravité du moment est à la mesure de
la menace à laquelle nous faisons face
le président de la république ne s'y est
pas trompé le 15 septembre dernier à
l'occasion son allocation son allocution
d'ouverture de la conférence de paris il
a qualifié déj de menaces majeures qui
fait peser sur l'irak sur la région du
moyen-orient c'est sur le monde un
risque majeur
nous voulons saluer ici l'action ces
dernières semaines du président de la
république des premiers ministres des
ministres des affaires étrangères et de
la défense leur sens de l'anticipation
qui conduit aujourd'hui la france
assumer pleinement ses responsabilités
dans cette crise majeure et nous
voudrions aussi vous remercier monsieur
le ministre de la défense asik laurent
fabius ministre des affaires étrangères
pour avoir tenu régulièrement informé
les commissions des affaires étrangères
et de la défense du sénat et de
l'assemblée nationale
depuis plusieurs semaines sur cette
crise
en prenant d'emblée le parti d'affronter
cette menace la france relève un défi un
défi global un défi de civilisation
lancé à nos sociétés elle le fait en
toute légitimité dans un cadre
international
elle est en cette circonstance fidèle à
elle-même
parce que la france est un pays de droit
et que l'ampleur de la menace ne suffit
pas à elle seule à justifier une
intervention armée il est nécessaire de
rappeler ici la légitimité dans laquelle
elle inscrit son action il ne manquera
plus important de rappeler que c'est à
la demande des autorités irakiennes
qu'elle agit elle a été ainsi l'une des
première puissance à reconnaître le
nouveau gouvernement d'union nationale
dirigé par le nouveau premier ministre
haïdar al arabi c'était le sens du
déplacement en irak du président de la
république le 12 septembre dernier au
cours duquel il a témoigné de son
soutien
c'était un acte important qui
conditionnait notre intervention car
nous estimions comme d'autres d'autres
partenaires que ce gouvernement devait
être représentatifs et donc inclure à
une juste proportion les minorités en
particulier sunnite écarté jusque là des
responsabilités par l'ancien premier
ministre nouri al maliki
c'est donc à la demande d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale sein
d'une légitimité démocratique à laquelle
la france répond
les relations de la france avec l'irak
sont fortes et anciennes elles ont été
parfois teintées d'ambiguïté elles ont
été constamment guidé par l'amitié avec
le peuple irakien
ainsi si la france a participé à la
libération du koweït
elle a refusé d'intégrer une coalition
internationale en 2003 parce que les
raisons invoquées par nos alliés en
particulier américains ne nous semblait
pas reposer sur des preuves tangibles
que les vraies motivations sont les
ailleurs les relations entre nos deux
pays sont désormais normalisés et
doivent répondre à un souci de
réciprocité il est tout aussi important
de rappeler que l'intervention française
ne saurait déroger au droit
international et que c'est à une demande
du conseil de sécurité qu'elle répond
c'est le sens du communiqué du conseil
de sécurité du 19 septembre
je cite le conseil
prie instamment la communauté
internationale de renforcer et d'élargir
dans le respect du droit international
là puisqu'elle fournit au gouvernement
irakien dans sa lutte contre le il l est
les groupes armés qui lui sont associés
aujourd'hui même se tient un sommet
organisé par les nations unies consacrée
à la lutte contre la menace mondiale
créée par les combattants terroristes
étrangers cette prise de conscience des
moines y de la gravité de la menace et
le gouvernement n'a pas été en reste
puisque la france a très tôt ces parties
des états qui ont tenu à s'impliquer
dans la lutte contre des ch
elle a décidé d'accueillir sur son sol
des réfugiés irakiens 1,6 en août elle
avait déjà accueilli une première vague
issus des minorités menacées et samedi
dernier une seconde elle doit le faire
en prenant bien évidemment en compte des
liens existants avec des familles des
résidents en france et doivent seul
comté à nos yeux les souffrances
imposées par l'organisation terroriste
aux irakiens qu'ils soyez-y dix
chrétiens chiites aussi doute
la france a décidé très vite de fournir
de l'aide humanitaire d'urgence et à ce
jour plusieurs dizaines de tonnes ont
déjà été expédiées le président de la
république a d'ailleurs confirmé lors de
son déplacement en irak
le déploiement d'un véritable plan
humanitaire entre nos deux pays
elle a aussi livré des armes aux pêches
merga cure des armes qui ont permis à
ceux-ci de mieux tenir face aux éléments
dès ce soir de reprendre l'initiative en
témoigne par exemple la reprise du
barrage de mossoul de concert avec les
forces régulières irakiennes
elle a agi dans diverses enceintes
internationales afin que soit engagé une
action armée en conformité avec le droit
international et pour conférer une
dimension collective à la réponse ainsi
après avoir reconnu par son déplacement
à bagdad le gouvernement irakien du
nouveau premier ministre elle a organisé
une première conférence sur la sécurité
en irak le 15 septembre dernier à paris
en réunissent en pente et à cette
conférence a favorisé la coalition
internationale qui réouvre qui réunit
aujourd'hui une quarantaine d'états
enfin elle a effectué des missions de
reconnaissance et à frapper en
territoire irakien par nos chasseurs
rafale le 19 septembre dernier à partir
de nos forces prépositionnées aux
émirats un dépôt logistique près de
mossoul dans cette lutte contre le
terrorisme l'action de la france
s'inscrit dans une stratégie globale qui
répond à une menace elle aussi globale
comme l'actualité vient de le rappeler
encore avec cruauté il y encore quelques
heures des shs participe d'une logique
qui dépasse les territoires irakiens
syrien et menacent aujourd'hui
directement nos ressortissants
nous avons affaire à une échelle inédite
le terrorisme qui se répand sur de
vastes territoires d'afrique du mali au
sud libye et plus largement une grande
partie du sel en anticipation à cette
nouvelle dimension la france a
réorganisé en étroite coopération avec
ses partenaires locaux son dispositif
sur le continent africain dans le cadre
de l'opération barkan la france
soutiendra donc les autorités irakiennes
sur les plans logistique humanitaire
politique et par des frappes aériennes
mais ne déploiera pas de troupes au sol
ce choix obéit à des considérations qui
tiennent compte de l'expérience du passé
les troupes américaines se sont retirées
d'irak en 2000 ans et le souvenir des
côtes occidentales en irak est encore
trop récent pour qu'en retour ne suscite
des polémiques
la lutte contre le des chemins ce n'est
en toute logique dans cet affrontement
globale dans un même continuum
géographique et temporelle mais en dépit
de tous ses efforts humanitaires
diplomatique et militaire
ces initiatives doivent être encore
complété élargi nous ne mènerons pas ce
combat seul avec les états unis et les
autorités irakiennes mais unis au sein
d'une coalition
face à un péril inédit dans sa forme et
si à court terme la lutte armée contre
des shu est un impératif stratégique est
une exigence morale au regard des
exactions qu'il commet la solution à
moyen et long terme ne peut être
naturellement que politique
parce que son idéologie la négation de
valeurs portées par nos sociétés parce
que ses accents d'une inhumanité
inqualifiable des jeux doit être
combattue ce mouvement né en 2003 contre
les états unis et le nouveau pouvoir
alors en irak la france avait déjà eu
affaire à lui il s'appelait alors
l'armée islamique en irak
et c'est cette même organisation qui
avait enlevé une journaliste française
son chef d'alors avait lancé les
premières attaques antichiites dès 2004
présent plus encore les fondations les
confrontations intercommunautaires
d'aujourd'hui nourrit d'une idéologie
sommaire les actes même de cette
organisation sont dénoncés par tous à
l'image de l'appel de paris lancé par
l'ensemble des organisations islamiques
française dont les signataires je cite
des noms sans ambiguïté les actes
terroristes qui constituent des crimes
contre l'humanité et déclare
solennellement que ces groupes leur
soutien et leur recrue ne peuvent se
prévaloir de l'islam ces agissements
d'un autre âge tout comme les appels à
considérer au jihad et les campagnes
d'endoctrinement les jeunes ne sont
fidèles ni aux enseignements ni aux
valeurs de l'islam
de même un haut responsable à la mecque
a dénoncé en août dernier à la suite
d'une déclaration du pape que
l'extrémisme et l'idéologie de groupes
tels que l'état islamique sont
contraires à l'islam sont le plus grand
ennemi de l'islam et les musulmans sont
les premières victimes la condamnation
est unanime sans appel
cette organisation n'est ni un état ni
islamique
si nous devons aujourd'hui qu'on va
idéologiquement et militairement dèche
presque posé la question du tarissement
des financements
ceux ci on le sait proviennent des taxes
sur les zones qu'il contrôle des
financements privés de multiples sources
de trafic de détournement de pétrole la
communauté internationale
doit chercher des réponses
opérationnelles à ces questions cette
organisation a prospéré hélas sur les
frustrations engendrées par les
impérities le régime de bachar al assad
en syrie et du gouvernement de nouri al
maliki en irak
la non prise en compte de la pluralité
pourtant multiséculaire de ces sociétés
et à encourager l'émergence de cette
entité dans ce qui est rappelons le l'un
des berceaux de nos civilisations
preuve en est que ce sont des solutions
politiques qui doivent être apportées à
la fois localement mais aussi à
l'échelle plus globale l'enjeu régional
est réel et l'engagement des états du
moyen-orient doit devenir effectif car
ce sont les premiers concernés et pour
nombre d'entre eux il s'agit bien d'une
question existentielle la turquie dont
on comprend qu'elle craint que le rôle
et la place des kurdes dans la lutte
contre cet organisme conforte
l'émergence d'un kurdistan autonome
comme pour d'autres états de la région
des garanties doivent être apportées
ankara sur l'intangibilité des
frontières
par ailleurs longtemps préoccupée par le
sort réservé aux sunnites d'irak la mise
à l'écart de l'ex premier ministre
irakien devrait faciliter une
participation plus effective de la
turquie
l'egypte qui subit elle même des
répercussions de groupes terroristes sur
son sol notamment dans le sinaï le liban
où l'islamisme sunnite et le hezbollah
chiite se livrent à une surenchère qui
met en péril les partis politiques
modérés l'arabie saoudite et le qatar
dans les assises monarchique sont
remises en cause par l'idéologie
salafiste
véhiculée par des ch qui privilégie un
vaste ensemble
communautaire dépourvu d'expression
institutionnel politique la syrie et
l'iran sont évidemment des cas très
particuliers
mais leur rôle respectif dans la
coalition est conditionnée ne peut être
négligé l'intégration de l'iran dans la
coalition est conditionnée à l'issue que
connaîtront les négociations sur le
nucléaire celle de la syrie est tout
autant par l'acceptation par le régime
de damas une solution politique entre
les différentes parties prenantes d'une
guerre civile où la responsabilité de
bachar el assad ne pourra jamais être
exclu pour la syrie un processus
politique semblable à celui qui sait
plus ou moins ce qui s'est en irak
pourrait constituer le fondement d'une
négociation entre les parties une action
concertée de ces pays au sein de la
coalition internationale
constituerait naturellement une percée
diplomatique majeur elle permettrait un
rééquilibrage par lequel les frontières
de ces états seraient consolidées et
leurs tensions internes stabiliser car
elle obligerait les régimes en place à
trouver des réponses politiques chez eux
tout en participant à une solution
politique globale
cette organisation lance un défi à
l'ensemble du monde le territoire
qu'elle veut contrôler le long du tigre
et de l'euphrate échappe à toutes
conventions internationales
rappelons le c'était aussi l'objectif
d'aqmi au mali ainsi un édifice aux
contours vagues mais organiser
émergerait un peu à l'image de celui
bâti par les talibans d'afghanistan où
le vase iris temps dans les années 90
comme l'actualité de ces derniers heurts
de ces dernières heures de ces derniers
jours le démontre dèche en engendre une
logique de multinationales du terrorisme
du même ordre que celle d'al qaïda des
groupuscules comme aujourd'hui en
algérie ou dans le sinaï où en afrique
subsaharienne demain et des individus
près d'un millier de français 10000
européen en syrie en irak se réclament
de cette organisation
comme ses dernières déclarations
incitent à le penser les risques
d'attentats sont donc accru pour les
pays occidentaux et ceux de la coalition
au delà de la lutte sécuritaire et
militaire qui va durer longtemps c'est
un défi lancé à l'ensemble de nos
sociétés lutter contre des shu est un
combat de nature civilisationnel tu ne
ramène au fondement de sociétés
libérales et démocratiques et
malheureusement à la fragilité parfois
de nos états de droit et en ce sens
l'absence des européens dans la
participation aux opérations militaires
interpellent
peut-être faudra-t-il poser cette
question à l'ordre du jour du prochain
conseil européen afin d'inciter à la
fois la nouvelle représentante de la
politique européenne sécurité commune
est la nouvelle commission a initié une
ligne plus clair sur un sujet essentiel
pour l'europe car comme le premier
ministre l'a récemment dit déj s'en
prend à nos libertés à nos valeurs
fondamentales pas seulement celle des
français celle aussi de tous les
européens enfin c'est parce que la
france ne doit pas déroger à ses valeurs
qu'elle s'engage dans cette coalition
internationale elle conservera son
autonomie d'appréciation dans les
objectifs militaires et encouragera la
plus large coopération avec les états
participants et ce en conformité avec le
droit international et dans le respect
de ses partenaires la france est une
fois de plus à sa place à la hauteur de
ce double défi combattre le terrorisme
et nous avons ce moment une pensée pour
nos militaires qui conduit ses missions
dans différents théâtres extérieurs et
en france et travailler à la recherche d
issue politique pour que cette région du
moyen-orient retrouve équilibre et
sécurité l'once
merci
la parole est à robert hue pour le
groupe rds
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la défense
mes chers collègues
le vaste le 29 juin dernier la
proclamation d'un califat bardèche sur
une partie de l'irak et de la syrie a
marqué un tournant majeur
même si nous étions déjà alerté depuis
plusieurs mois sur cette évolution
inquiétante
imposé avec barbarie par les djihadistes
ces dernières semaines nous avons tous
suivi
avec effroi la brutalité de l'avancée de
ces terroristes jusqu'à mossoul je
rappellerai les exactions commises sur
leur passage notamment à l'encontre des
chrétiens d'orient qui n'ont pas eu
d'autre choix que ceux de l'exil de la
conversion forcée ou de la mort la
france a d'ailleurs très vite mesuré la
gravité de la situation et à cet égard
je salue sa prompte réaction qui a
permis de mobiliser l'union européenne
dès le 15 août pour l'organisation d'un
pont humanitaire afin d'aider les
populations d'erbil
fidèle à sa tradition de protection des
minorités persécutées
notre pays a accueilli des réfugiés
ce dont je me réjouis également
dans ce chaos insoutenable je n'oublie
pas la violence de l'assassinât des
trois otages occidentaux qui illustre
une détermination sans borne pour ne pas
dire sans foi ni loi de cette judaïste
dont la prétendue ferveur n'a pas
d'autre ambition que celle d'une
domination absolue pour mieux propager
son obscurantisme
c'est contre cela que nous devons lutter
contre un mouvement qui fait de la
négation de l'être humain une politique
et contrairement à ce que prétendent les
communiqués de ces terroristes notre
engagement ancien dans la lutte contre
l'extrémisme islamiste n'est pas une
guerre de civilisation
tout au long de son histoire la france a
toujours noué des liens étroits et
mutuellement enrichissant avec la
plupart des pays du moyen orient et plus
globalement avec les pays musulmans
c'est d'ailleurs au nom de cette amitié
en l'occurrence au nom de celles que
nous avons souvent entretenu avec le
peuple irakien que nous ne pouvons pas
laisser des milliers d'hommes de femmes
et d'enfants se faire massacrer
bagdad a officiellement demandé l'aide
de la france alors comment ne pas y
répondre le président de la république a
donc décidé la participation de notre
pays à la coalition décidé à newport au
sommet de l'otan dans sa grande majorité
le groupe rds approuvent cette
initiative même si pour ma part tout en
étant lié au groupe j'émettrais quelques
réserves j'y reviendrai
selon les mots du président il fallait
rapidement agir pour affaiblir
l'organisation terroriste et venir en
appui des autorités irakiennes nous le
savons les forces armées irakiennes
auraient été débordées sans l'aide
efficace des puces merga kurdes dont il
faut souligner l'engagement l'armée
irakiennes doivent affronter une force
qui estimée à dix mille hommes seraient
selon les experts composée de 30 mille
combattants aujourd'hui le ministre nous
le confirmait ce matin en outre en
conquérant un territoire près de 40% de
l'irak les terroristes sont riches ils
mettent la main sur des axes
stratégiques des richesses naturelles et
organise les flux financiers vous l'avez
rappelé récemment devant les membres de
la commission des affaires étrangères
monsieur le ministre des chenilles
disposerait d'une manne financière
évaluée entre 1 et 2 milliards de
dollars et au fur et à mesure de son
avancée
cette réserve est exponentielle
il est donc il est donc temps de la
contenir car nous connaissons les visées
expansionnistes d'al bagdadi comme vous
le savez mes chers collègues le leader
de dh ne cache pas ses intentions qui
dépasse la syrie et l'irak la palestine
la jordanie mais aussi le liban figure
parmi ses objectifs
il veut réussir là où ben laden a échoué
face un tel dessein qui déstabiliserait
profondément et pour longtemps la région
nous ne pouvions pas rester passif un
large consensus s'est dégagé au plan
politique comme dans l'opinion en faveur
de l'intervention des forces françaises
en irak sur le terrain les premières
frappes aériennes ont eu lieu je
rappellerai cependant que tout doit être
mis en oeuvre pour épargner les
populations civiles qui n'ont déjà que
trop souffert
j'ajouterai que cette intervention est
également nécessaire pour la propre
sécurité de nos concitoyens
même si à court terme le risque de
représailles est réelle comme le montre
hélas l'enlèvement d'un français
en algérie j'entendais ma solidarité
c'est une très triste nouvelle je sais
monsieur le ministre que tout est fait
pour éviter le pire en coopération
notamment avec les autorités algériennes
d'autre part comme vous l'avez aussi
exposé à plusieurs reprises monsieur le
ministre
l'organisation de filières sur notre
territoire d' apprenti terroriste expose
les français à une menace croissante
mais je sais aussi que tout est mis en
oeuvre pour que notre pays dispose
d'outils toujours plus efficace je pense
à l'action des services de renseignement
à vigipirate et à notre législation sur
la lutte contre le terrorisme nous
aurons l'occasion d'en discuter ici dans
quelques semaines tout cela est positif
sans nous éloigner malheureusement du
risque d'un acte isolé mais je dirais
aussi au regard de l'incident je mets
des guillemets d'hier à propos du retour
de trois jihadistes français que se pose
la question des moyens des services de
lutte contre le terrorisme et leur
coordination
les prochains débats budgétaires
permettront d'en discuter monsieur le
ministre cependant vous pourrez
peut-être éclairer dès aujourd'hui ce
qui à ce qui apparaît comme je mets des
guillemets un raté si je devais
néanmoins exprimé quelques regrets
autour de cette intervention ce serait
tout d'abord celui du manque
d'implication
significative absolument inacceptable de
nos voisins européens
ce qui laisse finalement apparaître la
france derrière les etats-unis voir les
français bon élève et supplétifs d'une
stratégie purement américaine or la
france la france est forte dans ce monde
quand elle porte cette conscience et ses
valeurs affirmant plus que jamais sa
capacité d'intervenir en toute autonomie
et indépendance notre pays sonore du
combat conduit à son unité à son
initiative en afrique que ce soit au
mali et en république centrafricaine
mais peut-être tenir tous ces fronts je
pose la question et souhaite à
politiquement et en at elle les moyens
par conséquent gardons également pour
l'irak notre libre arbitre et je pense
en particulier à la question de
l'extension de l'intervention de la
coalition en syrie les états unis
effectuent depuis peu des raids en
territoire syrien alors que ce point
n'avait pas été tranché au dernier
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
rappelons que notre décision
d'intervenir a été prise avec l'accord
de bagdad
quelle est la position de la france sur
ce point monsieur le ministre ensuite
cette intervention dont son sol format
militaire si nécessaire soit elle ne
m'apparaît pas suffisante nous savons
pertinemment que l'absence de stratégie
globale le fait que différer les
problèmes nous ne pouvons que le
déplorer en irak où l'intervention de
2003 à laquelle je m'étais opposé et
dont la position de la france à l'époque
a fait honneur à notre pays n'a pas
apporté l'effet annoncé des ch est une
réminiscence hybride de l'idéologie d'al
qaïda et de l'ain surrection sunnites
contre l'occupation américaine des
années 2003 2008 après une intervention
militaire alliée dans un pays en crise
la question reste souvent entière
comment contribuer à une solution
politique dans le cadre d'une stratégie
diplomatique dans laquelle la france et
l'europe peuvent prendre une place
majeure et indépendante dans ce pays et
au delà nous sommes dans une situation
complexe où la lutte d'influencé entre
les sunnites le sunnisme et le chiisme
minoritaire compliquer les choses or le
gouvernement iraqien d'al maliki a
concentré tous les pouvoirs et n'a pas
intégré toutes les communautés
contrairement aux dispositions de
l'accord d'erbil de novembre 2010 dans
cet esprit il est temps que tous les
pays concernés de la région que ce soit
les pays en crise mais aussi les acteurs
incontournables comme l'iran ou l'arabie
saoudite participe sans ambiguïté à une
stratégie commune car seule la
coexistence de toutes les communautés
jugulera terrorisme qui se nourrit de la
marginalisation et de la paupérisation
qui en découle bien souvent comment
aussi imaginer dans cette partie du
monde une solution durable qui ne se
seraient pas la russie et la chine
dans cette perspective du côté de la
diplomatie occidentale
je pense qu'il faut intensifier les
efforts en faveur des règlements
politiques car l'intervention militaire
est une réponse d'urgence mais
certainement pas la voie de la paix les
chers collègues la france a pris ses
responsabilités
en décidant de contribuer à elle les a
éliminés dèche le visage inquiétant du
fanatisme le plus monstrueux comme je
les dis le groupe rds soutient cette
entreprise qui doit s'accompagner d'une
réflexion stratégique plus profonde et
d'une aucune action diplomatique soutenu
avec la communauté internationale dans
le cadre et sous l'autorité de l'onu
merci la parole à andré gattolin pour le
groupe écologiste
voilà
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la défense mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues il ya un an presque jour pour
jour nous étions dans cet hémicycle pour
débattre d'un possible engagement de nos
armées suite à la terrible tournure
prise par la guerre en syrie à l'époque
un an plus tard nous nous retrouvons ici
pour évoquer un sujet presque similaire
et concernant la même région mais en
l'espace de douze mois la situation sur
place après une dimension qui est en jeu
qui ajoute encore de l'aurore extrême à
ce qui paraissait déjà à l'époque le
pire de l'horreur hier en effet l'usagé
d'armes chimiques contre les populations
civiles en syrie représentait le plus
haut degré de violence jamais atteint
dans ce conflit depuis la guerre dans la
région a franchi un seuil de barbarie
presque impensable nouveaux déplacements
de population
exécutions sommaires massacres de civils
actes de tortures et viols massifs une
terreur sans limite qui bien au-delà de
la syrie s'étend désormais à l'irak
voisin
devant cette tragédie la communauté
internationale se croûte trouve de fait
acculé nous n'avons d'autre choix que
d'intervenir pour tenter de venir en
aide à des populations prises au piège
et pour enrayer la progression d'une
entreprise terroriste
d'une ampleur jamais connue auparavant
de ce point de vue soyons clairs le
groupe écologiste du sénat ne peut que
soutenir la décision du gouvernement de
participer à la coalition internationale
qui se met en place depuis plusieurs
jours une participation de la france
certes toujours risqué comme toute
participation un conflit mais une
participation d'emblée voulu et affirmer
comme très limité par le président de la
république d'une part parce que nos
moyens dans la région demeurent modestes
et que l'essentiel de nos capacités
d'intervention extérieure et déjà
mobilisés sur d'autres théâtres d
opérations notamment en afrique
subsaharienne
d'autre part parce que notre action
s'inscrit dans un cadre de stricte
légalité internationale nous répondons à
une demande pressante d'assistance de
l'état irakien nul besoin donc dans ce
cas précis d'une résolution de l'onu
pour autant nous savons tous que nous ne
sommes pas ici dans la meilleure des
configurations pour mettre fins
exclusivement à coups de frappes
aériennes un conflit horriblement
complexe et sanglant nous pouvons certes
contribué à contenir la progression des
djihadistes du soi disant état islamique
de l'irak et du devant dans le nord de
l'irak pour peu que les peshmergas
kurdes n'enregistre pas au sol de
nouvelle défaite et que l'armée
régulière irakienne en cours de
reconstruction voit sa capacité
notamment aériennes devenir très
rapidement opérationnel mais nous le
voyons bien ces derniers jours le corps
du conflit s'est largement déplacer vers
la syrie aux frontières aussi de la
turquie et du liban c'est la raison pour
laquelle les états unis et cinq pays
arabes ont choisi depuis lundi de
procédé aussi à des frappes aériennes
dans certaines zones de la syrie dans
l'idée d'une opération visant à contenir
ou à des structures et militairement les
troupes de dèche cette intervention en
syrie même si elle sort du strict droit
international peut passage d'ailleurs
s'interroger sur l'existence aujourd'hui
donne l'état syrien reconnu le gall et
cohérent et bien cette intervention une
logique peu discutable nous sommes même
légitimement en droit de nous poser la
question est de savoir jusqu'où la
volonté affichée par les états unis de
ne pas engager de troupes au sol permet
lui permettrait de tenir les objectifs
politiques et militaires qu'elle s'est
fixée dans l'hypothèse d'un engagement
au sol le conflit entre ray alors dans
une autre dimension avec son cortège de
risquer de conséquences contradictoires
à court et à moyen terme disons le
clairement cette hypothèse ne concerne
pas directement la france d'une part
parce que comme nous l'avons dit
précédemment nous n'en avons pas les
moyens militaires et d'autre part parce
que la sagesse passé de notre diplomatie
qui nous a tenus à l'écart d'une telle
participation
durant la guerre en irak en 2003 nous
protège je crois d'une escalade dans
notre engagement mais s'il faut bien
garder en tête que se contenter de
frappes aériennes ou plus largement
d'une opération militaire ne suffira pas
instaurer la paix dans cette région la
réponse à ce conflit est nécessairement
une réponse politique et diplomatique et
non pas seulement une réponse d'urgence
à la fois humanitaire et sécuritaire
c'est vrai dans la plupart des cas comme
ça l'est ici tout particulièrement à
chaque fois qu'une intervention
extérieure était déclenchée dans la
région c'est malheureusement in fine est
traduite par l'apparition de nouveaux
groupes armés de nouvelles factions aux
objectifs plus radicaux il est impératif
donc de tirer les enseignements des
échecs passés si nous voulons enfin
pouvoir mettre en place les conditions
d'une sortie par le haut à cette
succession de conflits est clairement
les conditions de cette sortie de crise
suppose d'engager très vite par les
voies d'un règlement politique et
diplomatique qui qui pourrait prendre le
relais de l'actuelle réponse militaire
en la matière et je reviendrai plus loin
la france et l'union européenne retour
rôle d'initiative majeur à jouer mais
pour bien comprendre l'enjeu auquel nous
sommes confrontés il est nécessaire je
crois de revenir rapidement sur les
raison de l'émergence de ce prétendu
état islamique en irak et au levant et
l'origine des moyens humains logistiques
et financiers importants dont il dispose
aujourd'hui celui ci s'est constitué en
agrégeant des groupes parfois très
divers ayant souvent bénéficié de
l'appui de pays de la région qui
voulaient acier intervenir dans la
guerre de syrie ces groupes avant de
s'allier d'europe avec leurs anciens
sponsors et de se radicaliser
au stade actuel cette organisation
profite évidemment des prises de guerre
et des détournements de matériel opéré
en irak et surtout en syrie à l'occasion
des combats et du ralliement des groupes
dont je parlais précédemment il est
manifeste aussi qu'elle s'appuie sur
divers trafics et notamment le trafic de
pétrole pétrole qui provient des champs
pétroliers des zones du nord de l'irak
passer sous son contrôle il serait donc
intéressant d'identifier les
intermédiaires et les clients de ces
trafics et reste indre si possible cette
manne bien trop commode là encore cette
démarche requiert une coopération
internationale aussi prononcés que
possible
nous le savons les responsabilités dans
cette tragique évolution dans cette
tragique situation sont des plus
partagées et dans le même temps nous ne
pouvons en aucun cas nous contenter
d'établir si responsable l'été pour dire
avec lesquels de ses acteurs nous
voulons ou non travailler aujourd'hui
c'est difficile à admettre mais si nous
vous faisons cela si nous choisissons
nos interlocuteurs pour une paix futur
il y aura très peu de monde autour de la
table des négociations au moment où la
diplomatie devra succéder à l'action
militaire alors disons le tout net seule
une grande conférence internationale
mobilisant l'ensemble des puissances et
des acteurs concernés permettra
peut-être de sortir la région de cette
spirale infernale et dans cette
perspective nous ne devrons avoir aucune
espèce de tabou aucune réticence quand
bien même cela ne dédouane la personne
de ses responsabilités passées ni nous
permettra d'oublier les terribles drames
qui ont secoué ces pays cela veut dire
tout d'abord que les acteurs syrien dans
leur ensemble régime de bachar el assad
et opposants à ce régime compris devront
être associés à ces discussions que le
que l'iran le seul pays à même
aujourd'hui de parler avec la plupart
des parties à ce conflit ne pourra être
laissés à l'écart que la turquie dont le
rôle était là souvent ambiguës devra
clarifier sa position et on peut se
demander si elle n'a peut-être pas
commencer à le faire en accueillant
depuis peu sur son territoire des
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés kurdes
les principales victimes de la situation
actuelle cela signifie aussi que la
question du kurdistan et de son
autonomie devra tête bien sûr posé est
elle aussi poser son tableau la
politique du gouvernement irakien devra
elle aussi évolué et avec le changement
de premier ministre elle a commencé à le
faire pour apaiser les tensions passées
avec ces populations sunnites sans
oublier bien sûr la russie très
constante et très présente dans la
région via son appui au régime syrien
alors monsieur le président messieurs
ministre mes chers collègues apporter
une réponse durable à la situation à
laquelle fait face la communauté
internationale ne sera pas aisée mais je
crois qu'il est important de rassurer
aussi nos concitoyens sur un certain
nombre de points oui cette organisation
terroriste peut-être militairement
réduite peut-être même vaincu quoique
fortement équipés manifestement
déterminés ne sent pas être en mesure de
tenir durablement les territoire aussi
vaste que ceux sur lequel elle prétend
aujourd'hui exercer sa domination la
mobilisation des opinions publiques dans
de nombreux pays musulmans pour dénoncer
les exactions de ce prétendu et
hadzidakis judaïsme djihadistes pardon
ainsi que la participation directe de
certains des états arabes de la région
aux opérations visant à la réduire
témoigne à c'est de ce qu'il ne s'agit
en rien d'un choc entre civilisations
mais d'une lutte entre les civilisations
et ceux qui veulent leur porter atteinte
nous devons bien prend deux gardes en
france dans un contexte sociétal et
politique tendu à ne pas céder aux
facilités de l'amalgamme ni à la panique
nous devrons faire preuve de prudence
sur notre territoire en luttant
évidemment contre les possibles actes
terroristes mais aussi contre les effets
délétères de ces drames sur nos propres
consciences et sans minimiser l'impact
possible de la situation en syrie en
irak au sein de notre société rappelons
quand même que le conflit il se troue et
serait lots palestiniens tels qu'ils se
développent notamment depuis trois ans
est de loin celui qui suscite le plus de
patients dans notre opinion et
qu'instinctivement beaucoup de monde il
voit la source de bien d'autres conflits
y compris celui dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui
n'oublions pas non plus sept autre
bombes à retardement qu'est la libye et
dont la mise à feu semble déjà bien
enclenchée et dont les retombées
pourraient être considérables nous
devons avoir toutes ces questions en
tête et à l'esprit en même temps que
nous réfléchissons et agissons sur ce
qui se passe en irak et en syrie tous
ces conflits sont certes différents mais
il n'en reste pas moins liées à bien des
égards notamment dans les
représentations collectives vouloir
mettre fin à l'un d'entre eux c'est
vouloir mettre fin à tous les autres
alors j'en arrive à ma conclusion est au
rôle que l'union européenne au delà de
notre seul pays pourrait et devrait
jouer dans les mois et les années à
venir c'est peu dire aujourd'hui que
l'europe est absente de ce débat d'une
part en raison du caractère embryonnaire
des politique extérieure et de sécurité
européenne l'absence d'une véritable
défense européenne d'autre part des
divisions qui peuvent encore la
parcourir sur certains aspects et enfin
de manière plus conjoncturelle en raison
du renouvellement en cours des instances
dirigeantes de l'union se dit point là
ce point là sur l'europe en dit long sur
le chemin qui nous reste à parcourir
pour rendre l'europe plus efficace et
opérationnel en outre l'angleterre reste
totalement à l'écart de ce conflit sans
doute parce que david cameron se
souvient un peu trop de l'échec qu'il a
essuyées l'an passé au sujet de la syrie
les avis de sa propre majorité et devant
son parlement et pourtant l'union
européenne a une carte à jouer
plusieurs de ces états sont des acteurs
engagés sur la scène internationale je
pense à la pologne je pense à la
république tchèque aux pays bas au
danemark et à ce propos je voudrais
saluer l'action du ministre de la
défense et de son homologue danois qui
en juin dernier ont élaboré une
stratégie de coopération entre la france
et le danemark qui nous permet de sortir
de l' espèce de volonté jamais abouties
de travail concerté avec les
britanniques c'est vrai que nous avons
ici peut-être à travers les pays que je
viens de citer les embryons d'une
défense européenne qui pourrait se
mettre en place
l'europe aussi a su faire la
démonstration de son utilité dans les
discussions avec lui rend et elle
entretient une relation de longue date
quoique particulièrement tumultueuse
avec la région
son engagement dans ces dossiers
constituera sans doute le premier test
grandeur nature pour ses dirigeants une
fois que la nouvelle commission sera en
fonction l'intervention est aujourd'hui
inévitable pour répondre à la crise
humanitaire et redonner de l'espace et
du temps à nos alliés locaux dans ce
conflit sachons utiliser au mieux ce
nouveau délai pour préparer une sortie
de crise ce qu'il soit enfin durable et
permettent d'associer au mieux
l'ensemble des peuples concernés je vous
remercie
merci la parole andré trillard pour le
groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la défense mes chers
collègues à quelques jours du
renouvellement du sénat nous nous
retrouvons pourtant cet après-midi parce
qu'il y a urgence
urgence face à l'inimaginable urgence
face à la barbarie
devant l'inhumanité des événements qui
se déroulent en irak depuis le mois de
juin la france ne peut rester immobile
alors que des centaines de personnes
sont exécutées en raison de leur
appartenance religieuse ou raciale le
massacre des chrétiens d'orient et
d'autres communautés par des extrémistes
nous avons nous rappelle qu'au 21ème
siècle nous n'avons pas tout à fait
terminé avec la folie génocidaire des
hommes
face à cette tragédie la france paraît
valeurs de liberté de respect des droits
de l'homme qui a toujours défendu la
france dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen a inspiré la
déclaration universelle des nations
unies la france membre du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies la france ne
peut rester inactive
face à une telle cruauté ne peut y avoir
de polémique il ne peut y avoir de
divisions
à ce stade qu'il me soit permis de
remercier les responsables des
communautés religieuses en france qui
ont fermement condamné la violence de
ces fous d'adieu qui leur tient lieu qui
leur tient lieu d'alibi pour lesquels la
radicalité d'une religion des caps
prétexte je veux particulièrement salué
les démarches de soutien des
responsables français de la communauté
musulmane
qui s'est engagé auprès de l'association
des chrétiens d'orient en danger je veux
le des saluts et également pour leur
langage de vérité et de paix ils ont su
rappeler que le meurtre la sauvagerie le
sectarisme ne sont pas des valeurs de
l'islam
quant à nous tous responsables
politiques français et européens et tous
nos homologues à travers le monde nous
nous devons ouvrir lucidement les yeux
sur la réalité de cette menace qui pèse
sur nos peuples
pour sa part attaché à l'unité nationale
c'est en toute responsabilité
que le groupe ump soutiendra le
gouvernement dans sa lutte contre le
terrorisme en france en irak et dans le
monde
au nom de notre groupe je me dois de
rappeler ici que la france et les
français ont déjà connu les menaces il
subit le terrorisme sur le sol national
comme à l'étranger
ils ont été les victimes de mouvements
fanatiques des tournants et
instrumentalisant la religion musulmane
pour le compte de leur folie
il en est de même pour nos alliés belges
espagnols et britanniques pour ne citer
qu'eux il est temps de prendre la vraie
mesure des nouvelles réalités du
terrorisme global
il est temps d'adopter une grille de
lecture cohérente des attentats de ces
dernières années qui dépasse très
largement la méditerranée paris en 1995
madrid en 2004 et londres en 2005
marrakech en 2011 des assassinats de
mohamed merah chez nous la prise
d'otages à in aménas 100 d'algérie en
janvier dernier la tuerie de bruxelles
il ya quelques mois sans oublier les
soldes algériens tués en kabylie au
modjo à la l'italie de ces macabres
événement démontre que nous avons
franchi un cap
l'europe comme territoire tout entier
est concerné chaque rue chaque
ressortissant européen à l'étranger
devenu une cible potentielle
l'enlèvement de notre compatriote
qu'elle nous pensons tous aujourd'hui
est l'illustration la plus récente
l'augmentation du nombre d'enlèvements
est proportionnelle à la cruauté de ceux
qui disent agir au nom du djihad il n'y
a pas de mots assez durs pour qualifier
la terrible mise en scène des
décapitations de journalistes
d'humanitaire de civils
aujourd'hui les responsables politiques
doivent faire face à une double menace
la surenchère de mouvance mouvance
terroriste pluriel
l'embrigadement d'individus via internet
rives en rêvant de faire les classes si
cette expression
encore servir
dans des camps d'entraînement au
pakistan au yémen ou en syrie
les cartes ont changé
il ne s'agit plus seulement de nébuleuse
qui est clairement identifiable comme al
qaïda
ou aqmi au sahel il ya désormais
l'émergence de sectes comme boko haram
en afrique de l'ouest et aujourd'hui
nous sommes face à des jeunes dont les
ramifications se situe en syrie je
reviens dans les plus graves ces
organisations sectaires se voit talonné
par d'autres réseaux tout aussi criminel
organisé ces raisons on trouve des
soutiens opportuniste au sein de telle
ou telle tribu ou de telle ou telle
communauté
depuis la mort de ben laden
ces groupuscules sont en rivalité
permanente
ils sont en quête de reconnaissance sur
la scène internationale
tous considèrent que leur barbarie est
un gage de la crédibilité politique et
tous jouent de leur médiatisation
mais je veux rappeler ici que le fléau
du terrorisme
quelle que soit
l'appartenance de ces acteurs trouve ses
origines d'abord
dans la déliquescence des structures
étatiques si ces factions contrôle des
régions entières du monde c'est parce
que des états se sont effondrés nous
l'avons vu au mali elles sont à tête de
ces structures sur la tête de de trafic
de drogue d'armes et d'être humains qui
ne connaissent pas de frontières pour
l'irak il faut comprendre et se souvenir
que les irakiens n'ont jamais cessé
depuis dix ans de vivre sous la terreur
combien d'attentats combien de morts à
bagdad depuis 2003
le retrait des troupes américaines n'a
strictement rien changé
faut le dire clairement l'état islamique
d'irak et du levant aînés décembre de
deuxième guerre d'irak
la communauté internationale s'est
détourné de ce pays
comme tout comme les membres de dèche
sont légitimées par les trois années de
guerre en syrie où bachar el assad
continue de sacrifier la population
et alors même qu'il ya quelques années
lui-même n'avait pas comment combattu
ces terroristes avec autant d'énergie il
ya un an je le rappelle dans ce même
hémicycle il était question d'intervenir
en syrie contre un dictateur usé d'armes
chimiques contre son peuple
aujourd'hui force est de constater que
la france doit combattre le même ennemi
que bachar el-assad
dans cette redistribution
géopolitique total au moyen-orient
ni les interventions de la france
ni celles des états unis ou des
britanniques n'aboutiront sans une
clarification des puissances régionales
de la même façon il importe de
comprendre que les luttes entre les
différentes obédiences religieuses au
sein du monde musulman sont plus que
déterminante
partant de là monsieur le ministre
plusieurs questions essentielles se pose
que pouvez vous nous dire de
l'implication de la jordanie l'arabie
saoudite du qatar du bahreïn à l'heure
où les états unis ont mené une offensive
en syrie
lors de votre audition conjointe par les
deux commissions la semaine dernière
vous avez déclaré que la france
resterait libre de ses décisions
stratégiques qu'en est il à cet instant
qu'en est il des livraisons d'armes aux
rebelles syriens d'hier potentiel
ennemis d'aujourd'hui
est il besoin en effet de souligner que
nous devons rester très vigilants quant
aux futurs équilibres dans ces régions
rappelons que nous livrons également des
armes aux kurdes nous savons bien qu à
terme l'unité de l'irak sera mise en
question
a pour que lors de la deuxième guerre
d'irak le président jacques chirac avait
marqué sa différence avec la politique
de l'administration bush
qui souhaitaient une nouvelle carte
géopolitique de la région
non c'était chirac
ouais on est d'accord et s'était opposé
à cette guerre
et avait refusé dire d'y entraîner la
france c'est tout à la fois inspiré de
ce message d'indépendance de l'époque et
animés de la volonté de paix à long
terme pour la région que la france
d'aujourd'hui agir dans ce contexte il
importe que notre pays engagent un
dialogue sincère
et exhaustif avec la turquie
très sensible à cette question du
kurdistan
ce pays connaît lui aussi les affres du
terrorisme
par ailleurs il doit la gérer l'afflux
de milliers de réfugiés syriens fuyant
le régime d'assad mais parmi ce n'est
qu'ils peuvent se cacher de nombreux
membres des groupuscules terroristes
l'europe doit aussi se préoccuper des
problèmes des réfugiés en turquie
nous l'avons vu hier soir avec cette
grave affaire des jihadistes français
qui transitent aussi par la turquie nous
aurons l'occasion de ré interroger le
gouvernement sur ce sujet à la lumière
de ces nouveaux transit qui mêle des
réfugiés entrants des djihadistes en
partance
l'union européenne doit rapidement
reconsidérer sa politique des frontières
l'espace schengen a été créé en temps de
paix
la guerre contre le terrorisme est une
bataille de longue haleine
il faut que les européens s'adapte cette
nouvelle situation les pays européens
doivent en sambre examiner la pertinence
des accords de schengen dans cette
situation de terrorisme dirigé contre la
communauté européenne et vis-à-vis de
ceux qui participent à cette lutte
contre la communauté européenne sinon
j'ai bien dit ensemble si nous soutenons
gouvernement sur le principe
d'intervention de nos forces aériennes
en irak je veux rappeler qu'aucune
politique de défense ne pourra se
substituer à la mise en place d'une
diplomatie globale au moyen-orient que
ce soit dans la résolution du conflit
entre la palestine et israël qui dure
depuis l'année de ma naissance
en syrie
en libye et en irak
d'autre part plus que jamais la france a
besoin d'être assemblés et unis dans
cette épreuve
notre première réponse aux menaces c'est
l'unité nationale alors ne comptez pas
sur nous pour attiser les polémiques la
france ne souffre déjà que trop
toutefois monsieur non il ne s'agit pas
d'un blanc seing
ainsi cet animé de ce même esprit de
responsabilité que nous vous invitons
vivement à reconsidérer de toute urgence
les crédits consacrés à nos armées en
particulier ceux dédiés aux opex certes
il ya les financements interministériel
mais nul n'est dupe ils ne suffiront pas
d'autant plus qu'ils ont déjà
partiellement servies à d'autres opex
nous nous étions exprimés sur ce point
lors de l'examen de la lpm nous vous
avions alerté tous ensemble sur la soupe
budgétisation des opex et ce d'autant
plus c'est d'autant plus vrai que les
recettes exceptionnelles
ne sont pas toutes au rendez vous
cet après midi nous l'avons dit il
s'agit pour la représentation nationale
de faire preuve de responsabilité
il s'agit aussi de témoigner notre
respect à l'endroit de nos soldats leur
professionnalisme et leur dévouement et
leur endurance sur l'honneur de la
france et ne force armée
or nous savons bien qu'il ne bénéficie
pas toujours des meilleures conditions
pour leur sécurité que leur moral est un
peu atteint nous avons abordé à ce sujet
à la commission des affaires étrangères
et de la défense normalement dans
notamment retour de nos collègues de
république république centrafricaine qui
sont comme on vous avez interrogé sur ce
bois dans une séance de questions au
gouvernement
au nom de la france
pour le président de la république a
répondu à l'appel à l'aide du
gouvernement iraqien à ce stade où nous
l'avait confirmé la semaine dernière
monsieur le ministre il ne sera question
que d'opérations aériennes
quoi qu'il en soit on cette guerre il
faudra des alliés impliqués à cet égard
nous ne pouvons que nous réjouir de la
réaction et de l'implication de
l'algérie qui lutte avec ses alliés
fermement contre les djihadistes
mais le président et je ne crois pas
être le premier à le dire
de la république doit aussi toute
urgence réussir à mobiliser nos
partenaires européens
elle exhorte les exhorter à voir la
réalité du monde
être européen ce n'est pas seulement
répondre à des critères d'endettement
c'est primordial mais quand il en va de
la sécurité de l'europe et du monde
l'agenda européen ne peut se cantonner à
des questions de croissance ou de
déficit
la france est consciente qu'elle doit
respecter ses engagements économiques
mais il faut que nos partenaires
respectent aussi les leurs en matière de
sécurité et de défense
avec les seuls britannique notre pays ne
peut assurer la défense des 28 états
membres
le seul ministre ainsi que je les dis
précédemment le soutien de tous nos
concitoyens à l'engagement de notre pays
a fait le choix est essentiel est la
première réponse aux menaces que nous
devons éradiquer ces l'unité nationale
ce soutien et cette unité il vous
appartient de l'obtenir il des parents
sur la durée de la poursuite de la
clarté des réponses que vous apporterez
or aux français qui se posent
légitimement qui se les posent
légitimement et que la représentation
nationale worley en cet hémicycle je
vous remercie
merci
la parole est à yves pozzo di borgo pour
le groupe udi uc
je
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
après la libye le mali la centrafrique
la france une nouvelle fois appelé à
assumer ses responsabilités sur la scène
militaire internationale
je tiens à le dire d'entrée de jeu
monsieur le ministre
l'ensemble des membres du groupe u10 eu
ses soutiens cette invention française
en irak et nos premières pensées vont
donc à nos soldats et nos pilotes qui
s'endort et déjà engagé dans l'espace
aérien de l'irak ainsi qu'à leurs
familles je dirais que le groupe udc est
au garde à vous pour soutenir nos armées
quand elles sont en lice en extérieur
toutefois nous ne pouvons nous en tenir
là le pathos de la guerre nous fait trop
souvent perdre de vue ses motifs et ses
objectifs ce nouveau conflit doit être
lu tout d'abord au prisme plus large la
prolifération d'une nouvelle génération
de terroristes dans l'ensemble de l'air
arabo musulman et dans l'ensemble de
leurs mules mans avant de pouvoir
mesurer les implications opérationnelles
concrètes de notre intervention en irak
l'état islamique est un cancer
géopolitiques nés de l'échec de
l'intervention américaine en irak et de
l'incapacité du président bachar al
assad permettent une vie démocratique
dans son pays et de la puissance de la
scène internationale à résoudre la
guerre civile syrienne qu'elle a suivi
qui sévit depuis 2011 l'état islamique à
cheval sur les confins de la syrie et de
l'irak constitue une menace sérieuse
pour la sécurité la paix internationale
ce khalifa au trot autoproclamé a des
ambitions territoriales large et des
ressources importantes un armement
solide et de nombreux soutiens parmi les
tribus sunnites et les anciens officiers
de saddam hussein j'avais déjà relaté le
gouvernement sur la gravité de cette
situation le 19 juin dernier par une
question d'actualité lorsque je me suis
ému du sort fait aux chrétiens d'orient
les yézidis notamment été victime de tb
action à mesure comment c'est les
troupes de l'état islamique
notre opinion publique n'était pas
sensibilisé à ce sujet des chrétiens
d'orient depuis on a pris conscience et
je voudrais me féliciter de l'action du
gouvernement comme l'action du maire de
sarcelles qui a reçu l'archevêque de
kirkouk ce dimanche dernier où la mairie
du 7e arrondissement qui aujourd'hui
consacre toute sa journée aux chrétiens
d'orient la prise par les djihadistes
moss ou le 9 juin a montré que la
démocratie irakienne demeure trop faible
pour contenir le péril intégriste c'est
là le problème endémique du monde
arabo-musulman à l'heure actuelle les
dictatures sont remises en cause ou ont
été fragilisés par le mouvement des
printemps arabes
mais à démocratie demeure trop faible
pour s'imposer avec vigueur le 10 le
10/10 jadis mssi misant cette faille en
véhiculant un imaginaire héroïque de
reconstitution de l'oumma la plus large
qui soit
dès lors ne pouvons pas regarder
l'actuel intervention irakienne comme un
cas isolé le problème réel est beaucoup
plus large le djihadisme est une menace
globale état islamique n'a n'est que
l'un des avatars ce cancer géopolitique
empoisonné situation internationale déjà
particulièrement tendues avec la guerre
civile syrienne et tension des mythes du
liban tout en menaçant la palestine
jordanie mais aussi la turquie se
khalifa terrorise qui est au khalifat
history ce que la caricature est à son
modèle n'est pas un cas isolé boko haram
du nord nigeria s'est également érigé
comme tels l'afrique est donc également
touché là j'irai également la
spécificité du père et que nous fait
courir le doj qui à la fois à sa
proximité géographique dans l'immédiat
vos chères d'europe mais aussi à ses
activistes une nouvelle génération de
djihadistes émergent où il avait cité le
chiffre près d'un milieu de nos
concitoyens seraient sur place certains
spécialistes parlent de dos du triple
pour le parc autre exemple ils sont
partout le kazakhstan une à 300 dans ce
peuple de musulmans modérés nous pouvons
donc colérique un sanctuaire jihadistes
se constitua quelques heures d'avion de
l'europe notre continent est bien trop
vulnérable
aucun état européen n'a de solution
définitive contrôler la folie meutrière
de cas isolés nos propres concitoyens à
l'étranger sont désormais menacés
depuis 91 et l'opération tempête du
désert presque toutes les grandes
opérations extérieures internationales
ont lieu dans les pays arabes riches en
pétrole le raccourci est simpliste il
n'échappe pas nécessairement une analyse
historique détaillé mais c'est ainsi que
l'histoire récente et lui parler grand
pays musulman du monde or il n'est ni un
problème strictement cliente à l'offre
icm orientale en effet le terrorisme
rami islamiste a pendant longtemps été
traité comme un simple problème
sécuritaire
c'était le cas pour les américains avant
l'attentât contre les tours du world
trade center du 11 septembre 2001
cet attentat a montré aux américains et
au monde que c'était pas un problème
terroriste mais un problème politique
mondiale et il semble d'ailleurs au
regard des documents découverts en mai
2011 dans la cache de ben laden
quand nous lisons que tous ces documents
que celui-ci conserver le djihadisme
comme un projet politique global quand
nous lisons ces documents qui sont paris
on se demande si ben laden était pas à
la fois
marx et lénine un penseur et un
organisateur il semblerait que malgré
l'affaiblissement d'un caïd a remplacé
par les islamistes dash la diffusion de
son idéologie guerrière bouscule le
monde arabe mais aussi le monde musulman
dans son ensemble le cancer djihadistes
fera partout et tout le monde
l'interventionnisme occidental suscite
aussi des réactions épidermiques sur
l'ensemble du continent asiatique
gardons nous de jouer une fois de plus
sa mélodie du fardeau de l'homme blanc
la question de jadis n'est pas un
problème seulement quillan talent c'est
devenu un problème global dans les
percussions sur les répercussions sont
mondiales nous balayons une zone grise
et notre apparaît nettement après nous
sommes intervient l'afghanistan pour
couper les racines de qaïda et du régime
taliban qui les soutenait nous sommes
intervenus en libye et nous allons
déstabiliser la région nous sommes
intervenus au mali pour les mêmes
raisons et voilà qu'un nouveau
sanctuaire terroriste émergents
frontières de la syrie de l'irak à fort
départ pileggi à dix nous prenons le
risque qu'ils ne se regroupent à
l'avenir dans d'autres pays de l'air
arabo musulmane aux musulmanes ou même
de l'asie ou de l'asie centrale où se
trouveraient déjà plusieurs centaines de
jihadistes mais aussi des talibans et en
asie centrale s'étant récemment avec le
sénateur du lait crème beaucoup le
départ des alliés de l'afghanistan parce
qu'ils craignent vraiment que l'ensemble
de cette région soit déstabilisée par
les talibans la déstabilisation de ces
états sur un véritable drame
mais quelle solution politique pour nous
apporter le président de cette existence
septembre dernier devant le sénateur du
lait le sénateur michel boutant et moi
même c'était récemment ému d'observer
que l'essentiel des interventions
extérieures de l'onu avait pour théâtre
d'opération des pays musulmans
l'encore prenant gars ne pas jouer
l'occident contre l'orient des solutions
politiques aux défis aux logiques au
défi logique posées par le djihadisme
doivent être formulées par les pays
musulmans 1 me eux-mêmes ainsi le
kazakhstan qui je rappelle à plus 300 g
à dist accueilleront 2015 un grand
congrès religieux de l'ensemble du monde
musulman modéré du maroc à l'indonésie
tous les pays musulmans se regroupent et
réfléchissent aux solutions
structurelles apportées de le plan du
califat voilà une réponse au problème
fondamental de l'équation
quelles institutions peuvent parvenir
endiguer la prolifération du jihadisme
et comment la démocratie peut-elle
s'imposer dans l'air arabo musulmane
comme un modèle alternatif à dictature
au terrorisme dès lors d'importantes
questions se posent quant à nos
objectifs et aux moyens dévolus à notre
mission en irak première question le
périmètre votre intervention
le dash s'implanter en irak en syrie
mais aussi au liban et peut-être ainsi
d'arthur qui en jordanie la demande du
gouvernement irakien nous permet donc
pas de mener une action globale contre
l'ensemble du groupe armé
d'importantes questions se posent du
point de vue de la légalité
internationale
la paix lancé le gouvernement irakien
autorise dans le cadre défini partie 51
grâce aux deux nations unies à employer
la force contre l'état islamique mais
dans les seules limites des frontières
irakienne cette limite a été rappelé de
nombreuses fois il a eu raison par le
président de la république par le miz
affaires étrangères et que parent ou
même ceux de ministre toutefois la
situation est différente du côté
américain
barack obama n'a jamais caché son
intention de mener des frappes ce sol
syrien la loi américaine supérieure la
loi internationale
la loi américaine autorise l'emploi de
la force contre toute forme de
terrorisme islamiste ont pour certains
l'absence de demande expresse du
gouvernement de bachar al assad une
telle intervention n'est légale que s'il
est justifié par la ccim défend pas
légitime défense
des frappes américaines bachar al assad
a déclaré avoir été mis au courant par
les autorités américaines et je te
américaine prétendent que ces entrées
ambassadeurs venus crottés fait je ne
sais pas si c'est vrai mais ce sont les
dépêches console nous répondre et si
c'est vrai c'est déjà une reconnaissance
de fait du régime de bachar al assad et
c'est la question que je vous pose les
russe kriorus non respect du droit
international sont des spécialistes et
l'iran aussi le risque d'escaladé t-il
ben exclut les périmètres d'intervention
ne seront ils pas remis en question par
ces frappes américaines en syrie et
notre intervention pose inévitablement
la question de position ce dossier
syrien il semble que l'armée syrienne
d'après ce que disent des spécialistes
et là c'est l'incapacité d'agir en sol
quand les troupes de l'état islamique
aurons-nous à choisir je dis monsieur le
ministre on doit choisir mal de
déclarations péremptoires
que même sans évolution la transition
politique en syrie que nous soutenons et
avec raison à nous résigner à intégrer
réintégrer progressivement l'actuel
gouvernement syrien dans le règlement de
la crise provoquée par le lâche parce
que c'est bien gentil d'être péremptoire
mais la réalité est différente et c'est
pour ça que je vous pose la question
monsieur le ministre deuxième question
la forme de la coalition comment se
fait-il qu'une crise avec une telle
empreinte régionales et des
répercussions potentiellement aussi
large ne permettent pas un regroupement
des puissances les plus directement
menacée par la prolifération d'un
sanctuaire terroriste transfrontalier je
regrette aussi l'absence au sein de
cette coalition de deux puissances
régionales majeures que sont la russie
et l'iran la russie dispose d'une
expertise en matière de lutte contre le
djihadisme depuis à connaître et bien
leur géographie concernés du fait de ses
relations anciennes avec la syrie et
l'iran
l'un par akalé s'immisce au dossier
ukrainien l'isolent ils ont la russie
mais je pense que la russie aurait été
d'un plus grand socco pour nous d'un but
contre état islamique je vous rappelle
monsieur le ministre que pour preuve la
sphère ukrainienne fait que nous avons
suspendu le programme scandent ex
détection de terrorisme dans la foule de
coopération dans la lutte contre
terrorisme entre la france et la russie
c'est quand même aimant fort j'espère
que la citation de crédit ne se réglera
pour que nous puissions revoir tout cela
ne faut-il pas aussi ça c'est moi que la
collecte d'un thé goulet qui me vous
tire dessus ne faut-il pas aussi
regretté l'absence de l'iran dans cette
coalition
l'iran dit elle aurait un rôle
incontestable jeu de l'équipe cette
région l'état islamique vous présente en
effet une menace pour l'arc chiite pour
le hezbollah au liban pour la mira quien
essentiellement chi la coalition doit
même sur un plan symbolique marquer
l'opposition de l'ensemble du monde
musulman au cancer jihadistes elle
devrait réunir sunnites et chiites au
sein d'un projet commun
enfin je regrette une fois de plus que
la france ou le royaume uni soit
laissons donc la france pendant sont les
seules puissances du continent européen
supporter de fées d'essentiel
d'insécurité la diplomatie européenne ou
l allemagne ou l union européenne et
vous avez raison monsieur le ministre
vous avez répondu par un souhait la
défense opel né n'y est pas il serait
peut-être important si vous voulez que
ces pays qui l'entourent des leçons
puisse nous accompagnant les opérations
que l'on fait que l'on fait
courageusement troisième question à quel
point que nous sur nous notre ennemi
vous avez déclaré votre vote audition à
l'assemblée nationale monsieur le
ministre que l'état islamique serait
fort d'une cagnotte de près de 2
milliards de dollars d'où vient cet
argent qu est la position de la queue du
sergent comment cette étape à vient-il à
s'autofinancer at il à ses côtés des
états bailleurs de fonds ils exploitent
les champs pétrolifères des régions
qu'ils occupent mais à qui ventile son
pétrole et comment ne peut-on pas couper
les racines du mal à ses champs ses
finances quelle est la position de la
turquie qui est notre allié était membre
de l'otan est-ce qu'elle achète le
pétrole idem pour les circuits
l'approvisionnement en armes nous avons
armer les rebelles syriens est ce que
certains vous avez répondu non mais je
vous repose la question est ce que
certaines de ces armes n'ont pas rejoint
darche je sais que non pelées dit mais
c'est bien de répéter passe beaucoup
d'interrogations leur sont là dessus de
plus les paires semi par l'abbé bachar
assad et par amir actes en son temps de
gains matériels pour cet état islamique
nous avons pu constater le même
phénomène après la libye puisque
nombreux soldats et vous êtes vous avez
vous êtes un spécial de cela puisque
vous suivez ce problème là que nombreux
stocks d'armes conventionnelles étaient
pro fait proliférer jusqu'au nord du
mali en centrafrique avec les suites que
l'on connaît dernière question la
soutenabilité notre engagement en irak
du point de vue opérationnel dans son
intervention en libye nous avaient
conduits aux limites des possibilités
ouvertes par pro photo aérienne depuis
la loi de programmation militaire est
entrée en vigueur et de profond
mouvement traverse nos forces aériennes
sommes en capacité logistique de ménage
d'un autre mission en irak ne sont pas
sous dimensionné face à l'enjeu
l'opération en libye avait coûté plus de
170 millions d'euros 6 mai chiffres sont
bons qu'à sera-t-il pour l'irak sachant
que nous sommes engagés encore au mali
en centrafrique nous sommes également
présents liban au kosovo en côte
d'ivoire en guinée en asie centrale
notre défense est elle encore capable
décisif sur autant les tables
d'opération il manque plus d 1,5
milliard ce président si bien ça d'euros
au budget la défense pour suivre la
programmation est dessiné par la lpm ne
sommes donc pas sur le point d'arriver
au point de rupture de nos capacités de
projection les opérations extérieures en
coûter plus de 1,5 milliard d'euros de
plus que prévu est ce que nous pourrions
quid cps que nous pour comment elles en
hausse mais cela puisque nous avons les
pays du golfe avec nous puisqu'ils font
partie de la coalition est ce qu'il
pourrait peut-être nous aider quand vous
pensez que le prix des de surcoût des
opérations extérieures les opex milliard
600 millions c'est le prix d'un grand
magasin qu'ils ont acheté à paris une
seule de leurs achats peut-être
pourrons-nous leur poser la question
parce que nous sommes là surtout pour
les défendre enfin le cancer du
terrorisme islamiste je pose la question
monsieur le maire de celle de paris joue
à un très bel argent qu il nya paris
voilà et c'est nous allons les défendez
nos soldats vont les descendre enfin le
cancer du tyrol et en plus de ça ils ne
paient pas d'impôts mais autant le
savoir donc enfin le cancer du
terrorisme islamiste n'est pas sa seule
question d'un nul contre l'italie cela
me
nourrit la tva c'est tous mais pas les
apports à la baballe free pour paris
d'air c'est pas mal pour les mutations
immobilières à paris le monde musulman
et plus vaste le seul proche orient le
risque déstabilisation charriées par
djihadisme est donc très grand je pense
au pakistan dont je passe à l'indonésie
je pense aussi aux philippines al en ont
bombardé pour nous aller une fois les
responsables de son mouvement le tra
lisez et leurs bases et truites où
allons-nous enfin nous attacher à
trouver des solutions pour accompagner
la consolidation de la démocratie de la
liberté dans le monde et cela dans le
reste est l'autonomie du décès de ces
peuples à l'heure actuelle ces solutions
nous ne voyons pas une seule certitude
au delà de la nécessaire action
militaire gardons-nous à l'esprit que
seuls des solutions politiques issus du
monde musulman accompagnés par les
occidentaux permettront de régler ce
conflit idéologique je vous remercie
merci la parole est à présent un joueur
guillaume et l'âme pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'heure est
grave et quand vous annoncez monsieur le
ministre que l'opération chat mâle est
d'ores et déjà rempli de succès ne
faites-vous pas preuve d'une trop belle
assurance quelques heures seulement
après le début des frappes
c'était écrit dans la presse mais c'est
possible que vos propos était déformé
peu importe il me semble quand même que
le seul succès un verrait à ce stade est
celui de la communication
61% des français seraient favorables à
l'intervention française dont moi même
je tiens à le dire d'emblée vu le niveau
de popularité du président et du
gouvernement un sondage positif est en
effet un exploit notable mais soyons
sérieux
la guerre est un hack trop grave pour
l'instrumentaliser à des fins
politiciennes
considérée comme un succès le fait
d'avoir réussi à atteindre quelques
cibles s'est simplifié à outrance les
situation au moyen orient les méchants
serait clairement identifiés et tous les
moyens bon pour les abattre ce serait là
un peu trop manichéen et prêterait à
sourire si la sécurité mondiale n'était
en jeu
la situation n'est pas celle d'une armée
des fous de dieu avance en ordre de
bataille en terrain découvert pour
conquérir de nouveaux territoires et à
servir une population terrorisée elle
est celle de groupes ultra violent mais
dispersés dans des territoires en proie
depuis deux ou trois ans au chaos en
irak comme en syrie avec des alliances
ponctuelles et hétéroclite entre
factions et des populations locales
contrôle et non par la seule terreur
mais aussi par le rétablissement d'un
certain ordre public d'être social
intégré la complexité de la situation
est moins efficace sur le plan de la
communication mais cela change beaucoup
de choses dès lors des frappes aériennes
sont clairement insuffisantes oui elles
peuvent toucher des cibles stratégiques
mais elle seule elle ne modifieront pas
la situation sur le terrain
tout elle ne décideront pas de
perspective de sortie durable de crise
l'impasse libyenne le prouve si
l'objectif de l'intervention est de
protéger les populations civiles et de
neutraliser la menace que fait peser le
hisse sur le moyen-orient et le monde
alors le traitement de la question ne
saurait être purement militaire
l'urgence et d'organiser un gouvernement
irakien légitime associant toutes les
communautés n'oublions pas que le lie à
puiser dans le ressentiment des
populations contre lé régime irakien
l'essentiel de sa force tirons les
leçons des précédentes guerre en irak ou
en afghanistan
l'urgence est au rétablissement d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale associant
toutes les communautés les cheats bien
sûr puisque majoritaires dans la
population
les sunnites et les autres minorités
religieuses dont les yézidis et les
chrétiens avec bariza khiari et roger
karoutchi
nous travaillons au lancement d'un
groupe d'étude sur les chrétiens
d'orient
ici au sénat avec pour objectif de
réfléchir notamment aux moyens de
favoriser la réconciliation est
d'inverser la spirale de la violence qui
est en train de détruire le tissu de la
société irakienne
pour cela la solution ne peut venir du
ciel même par l'intermédiaire des
rafales ils font hélas des hommes sur le
terrain la coalition internationale l'a
bien compris et a choisi pour cela
d'armes et des rebelles locaux certes
cela est moins risqué vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique française ou
américaine
ni du point de vue géostratégique
n'est ce pas jouer à la roulette russe
est alimenté à monstrueuse engrenage
n'est-il pas insensé de déverser de
nouvelles armes dans le chaos moyen
orientale à des ailiers au profil
instable les liens entre les diverses
factions sont ambigus changeant certains
rebelles syriens sont comme d'âge des
sunnites parfois franchement extrémistes
ce n'est pas parce qu'ils ont fini par
se brouiller avec lui qu'ils en
deviennent des démocrates les modérés ne
représenterait que dit ça 15% des
rebelles syriens armée des islamistes
contre d'autres islamisme
machiavélique certainement mais pas
rassurant de même les combattants kurdes
sont proches du pkk fiché comme
organisation terroriste par les
etats-unis et l'union européenne alors
que le djihadisme tire sa force des
affrontements communautaires et
confessionnelles instrumentaliser les
uns pour neutraliser les autres est un
jeu de poker bien risqué s'attaquer une
des branches du terrorisme d'état
islamique sans se préoccuper de la
racine l'extension des groupes
jihadistes est allé au devant d'un
pourrissement assuré en irak on
intervient à la demande du président
pourtant très contestée par sa
population et qui n'a pas hésité à
bombarder des quartiers d'habitation
tandis qu'en syrie en armes des
combattants dont on espère qu'ils
déstabiliseront à la fois le président
et le lit la france a même longuement
refusé longtemps refusé des frappes en
syrie où le lit contrôle quasiment
autant de territoires qu en irak au
prétexte que cela pourrait aider bachar
al assad
sans nier ces exactions un peu de
pragmatisme vis-à-vis de la syrie serait
utile hubert védrine l'a rappelé
récemment contre hitler les démocraties
ont fait alliance avec spa lit malgré
tout le sens qu'il avait sur les mains
face à ces défis le manque de
coordination internationale est
désespérant certes la collection compte
théoriquement une quarantaine de membres
mais nombre d'entre eux n'ont une
implication que symbolique je pense à
particulier à la non association de
l'iran à la coalition qui me semble
insensé alors même que ce pays a été
l'un des premiers à combattre le lit de
même la russie et la chine principal
investisseur dans le pétrole irakien il
faut que tous les états membres de l'ue
eux comprennent que c'est aussi leur
sécurité qui est en jeu et qu'ils ne
peuvent nous laisser seuls en première
ligne il faut impliquer réellement tous
les belligérants états voisins dans la
recherche d'une solution politique au
lieu de ne leur laisser qu'une place de
figurant sur la question des
financements de l'aide logistique mais
aussi
la prévention de l'arrivée de renforts
viennent disque en syrie l'implication
de la turquie de l'arabie saoudite la
jordanie ou du qatar est cruciale une
véritable stratégie de sortie de crise
doit se préparer dès le début de
l'intervention ne nous laissons pas
aveugler par les seuls objectifs
militaires immédiat par des réussites
relativement facile alors que c'est
l'avenir de nos sociétés qui est en jeu
l'image d'une croisade franco-américaine
et ravageuse non seulement pour
l'acceptation par les populations
locales de cette situation mais aussi
pour nos propres ressortissants mis en
danger sur notre territoire national et
a fortiori dans le monde arabe cela nous
donne ici une image de suivent alors que
nous devrions avoir un rôle de moteur
dans la recherche d'une solution
politique concertée
une intervention sous l'égide de l'union
est impossible nous dit on le temps de
l'action ne serait-il donc pas le temps
de la négociation internationale
mais cela fait des mois voire des années
que la situation se détériore et que les
chrétiens d'orient appel au secours les
chancelleries se réveille un peu tard
nous avons d'ailleurs lancé en juillet
un appel parlementaires en ce sens ou
tel le président hollande n'a pas encore
apporté de réponse autre obstacle à
l'envoi d'une force d'interposition de
l'onu le probable veto russe là encore
comme pour l'iran je déplore qu'au nom
du politiquement correct l'on s'évertue
à écarter les russes de la table des
négociations
oui les russes sont venus à la
conférence de paris mais derrière les
photos de chagny que ce soit sur
l'ukraine ou sur l'irak et la syrie le
dialogue est très insuffisant
l'envoi d'une force d'interposition de
l'onu ne répondrai pas qu'un défi
stratégique immédiat celui de la session
cessation pardon des activités du
désarmement et de l'accès humanitaire
aux populations civiles elle serait
aussi tout dispensable pour la
crédibilité de la légalité
internationale
au lieu de cela les américains
bombardent de toute façon depuis plus
d'un mois sans mandat nationale il faut
d'une résolution du conseil de sécurité
nous nous cachons derrière l'article 51
de la charte des nations unies consacrée
à la légitime défense en indiquant
répondre à un appel à l'aide du présent
président irakien certes mais cet
artifice ne trompe personne c'est du
discrédit du régime irakien auprès d'une
grande partie de sa population et de son
incapacité à gouverner que le yi a puisé
sa force le président irakien est donc
loin d'être un interlocuteur
véritablement légitimes
d'où l'impérieuse nécessité d'une
intervention réellement internationale
sous l'égide de l'onu mépriser la
légalité internationale ni l'insidieuse
mans l'ordre mondial un jour viendra où
nous le regretterons j'en ai peur oui
l'onu doit être réformé pour répondre
plus efficacement et plus rapidement aux
défis du monde contemporain
mais elles offrent déjà un cadre non il
est regrettable de ne pas tenir compte
une mission de l'onu l'ama nuit et
depuis longtemps en irak et une
résolution du conseil de sécurité en
date du 30 juillet proroge même son
mandat jusqu'au 31 juillet 2015 elle
semble pourtant de jouer quasiment aucun
rôle dans la résolution de la crise
pourquoi ne pas s'appuyer davantage sur
l monsieur le ministre
personne ne conteste le bien fondé d'une
intervention face aux exactions commises
dont les responsables repompe répondrons
nous le souhaitons devant la cour pénale
internationale
il fallait agir pour protéger les
populations et notamment les chrétiens
les autres minorités persécutées pour
rassurer la sécurité régionale alors que
des états comme la jordanie le liban
sont à leur tour menacés pour éviter une
recrudescence de terrorisme
international à l'heure où des centaines
de jeunes partent se former au djihad
avant de rentrer sur nos territoires
pour peut-être perpétrer des attaques
mais si la cause est juste les moyens de
la servir sont aussi essentiels je mets
donc de réels doutes sur la stratégie
déployée
l'anéantissement du d'âge n'est pas une
fin en soi tout juste un objectif
tactique
c'est la montée de la violence
intercommunautaire et
interconfessionnels au moyen-orient
ainsi que le risque de propagation
mondiale du terrorisme qui doivent être
les véritables cibles il faut que nous
nous intéressions dès à présent scénarii
de sortie de crise à l'issue de la
campagne militaire en espérant que
celle-ci ne s'éternisera pas et au delà
de la neutralisation de neige afin
d'éviter la surenchère guerrière
construire la paix
souvenons nous de cette phrase de
churchill qui avait dit que l'irak avait
été créé un dimanche de folie la
position de jacques chirac avait
toujours été de dire que si l'on exclut
et les sunnites du gouvernement irakien
jamais nous n'arriverions à une solution
politique
ces paroles sont toujours d'actualité et
nous nous interrogeons sur la survie de
cet état et sur son intégrité
territoriale bien sûr
en irak une fois les objectifs atteints
qui contrôlera le vaste territoire
d'obédience sunnite modéré des
jihadistes retournera-t-il dans le giron
irakien participera-t-il d'une région
kurde autonome la forte implication des
kurdes dans le conflit ne fera t'elle
pas pencher la balance en faveur d'une
partition de l'irak en syrie cette
question de l'occupation des terres
libérées est encore plus critique
reviendront à la bachar al assad ou
rebelles sachant le poids minime des
modérés parmi eux seront ils capables de
contribuer à la reconstruction
économique et social du pays oui rouvert
des nouveaux déchirements
queen des trains tient dans ces deux
états
comment garantir leur sécurité le
respect de leur foi et de manière plus
globale
comment résoudre le problème palestinien
qui joue évidemment un rôle majeur dans
le ve l'enseignement de la situation
régionale il faut aussi que nous soyons
conscients des dangers sur le territoire
national le rapport de juin 2013 de la
commission d'enquêté de l'assemblée
nationale sur la surveillance des
mouvements djihadistes en france conclut
mai insuffisance de moyens humains
matériels et juridiques mises à la
disposition de nos services sur le sol
français
ceci explique peut-être aussi l'échec
retentissement retentissant pardon de
nos services dans la fin de l'année une
interception de membres de la famille
mayrand
mais je crois qu'il ya aussi urgence
observer une certaine décence
il est assis honteux et certainement
dangereux que certains pérore à longueur
de journée sur nos réseaux sociaux dans
les médias sur ces problèmes nous devons
être unis et surtout appelé à la
vigilance
en tant que sénatrice des français de
l'étranger et rapporteur à l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'otan sur le
terrorisme je suis particulièrement
inquiète des répercussions potentielles
sur la sécurité de nos ressortissants
deux millions et demi dans le monde dont
beaucoup facilement identifiable dans de
nombreux pays du moyen-orient et je
pense bien sûr à notre compatriote en
algérie monsieur le ministre
ils nous demandent cela il nous demande
d'être prudents dans nos paroles et
d'essayer de ne pas toujours tout dire
je comprends l'avidité de certains
médias vouloir organiser des débats même
si certains lesquels ichi parfois de
cash et du commerce pas toujours à tort
mais la sécurité de nos ressortissants
est en jeu et on ne peut pas laisser
tout dire on ne peut pas laisser dire
n'importe quoi parfois le silence est
d'or
il y a urgence monsieur le ministre à
renforcer les moyens des services qui
traite de la sécurité de nos concitoyens
en france et à l'extérieur
le projet de loi sur le terrorisme qui
vient d'être votée à l'assemblée
nationale et sera bientôt examinée au
sénat devrait y contribuer et j'exhorte
tous nos collègues tous nos compatriotes
quelles que soient leurs appartenances
politiques à soutenir nos forces armées
et nos forces de sécurité dans ce combat
contre la barbarie tout en veillant à ne
pas exacerber les temps sion
intracommunautaires ce n'est pas l'islam
que nous combattons c'est la bestialité
et l'ignorance d'une petite minorité
merci la parole est maintenant jean
louis carrère président de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la défense mes chers
collègues
à l'issue de ce débat très riche
beaucoup de choses un peu contradictoire
a quelquefois ont été vite qui témoigne
malgré tout d'une approbation très
majoritaire de la décision du président
de la république de faire intervenir nos
forces armées en irak de surcroît
monsieur le ministre vous avez dû goûter
com - les nombreux conseils parfois
convergents qui nous permettrons qui
vous permettront d'éclairer les choix à
venir il faudra quand même faire le tri
dans la somme deux de ses conseils pour
être tout à fait sérieux je crois que
avec l'état islamique
dénomination impropre temps le terme
d'état est inapproprié tout autant que
la référence à l'islam vous venez de
l'expliquer ma chère collègue nous
sommes en face d'un danger mortel
nous employons l'acronyme de dèche mais
il est l'exact traduction en arabe
d'états islamiques du devant du levant
je préfère un je préférerais avec
laurent fabius parler de khalifa de la
barbarie et de la terreur mais pour la
simplification des choses
j'utiliserai l'acronyme ce danger mortel
nous menace tous il faut que nous soyons
bien conscient de la viralité extrême à
laquelle nous avons à faire face
l'une de nos tâches comme responsable
politique elle est pour moi essentiel
est de bien faire prendre la mesure du
danger à nos populations et à nos
partenaires ne pas croire que l'opinion
publique réagit avec facilité et
complaisance à ce genre de défi il faut
expliquer et expliquer encore l'objectif
de dèche clairement affichée dans la
référence historique au califat
visez menace toute la région et bien
au-delà au delà de la syrie et de l'irak
ses prochaines cibles et vous l'avez
tout à fait dit seront le liban la
jordanie et bien sûr israël son
idéologie radicale se concrétise dans un
choix simple se soumettre ou mourir il
organise avec une violence extrême la
purification de tout ce qui n'est pas
lui et en particulier de toutes les
minorités qu'elles soient chrétiennes
chez ea payer ibis ou autres à ce titre
liront principale puissance chiite
considéré comme hérétique et directement
visés parmi ses commensaux sunnite il
condamne et considère comme un ami
l'arabie saoudite et les émirats
inféodés à l'occident cette menace n'est
cependant pas circonscrite au
moyen-orient elle est désormais globale
et recouvre ce que le livre blanc de
2008 auxquels nous avons beaucoup
participer appelez un arc de crise qui
va des zones tribales du pakistan au
golfe de guinée c'est un véritable
cancer qui se développe au gré des
faiblesses des pays des régimes et des
régions et des régions visées
que ce soit au levant en libye et en
tunisie au sahel ou dans la région du
lac tchad ses métastases se propage
aussi dans la corne de l'afrique
jusqu'au yémen le danger est bien
évidemment celui de la mise en synergie
en cohérence de cet international
terrorist les porosités à part est hélas
le ralliement de groupe largement
mafieux comme celui qui a pris en otage
l'homme de nos compatriotes en est l'une
des illustrations
nos ressortissants
et nos intérêts à l'étranger nos
concitoyens sur le territoire national
sont désormais des cibles cette menace
nous concerne directement singulièrement
en europe avec cette bombe à retardement
que sont les combattants étrangers nous
allons examiner dans quelques jours le
projet de loi sur le terrorisme est
aujourd'hui même un débat a lieu sur
cette question aux nations unies nous
savons bien que la probabilité d'un
attentat sur le sol français est forte
en dépit de la remarquable efficacité de
nos services que je tiens à saluer outre
le danger immédiat que représentent des
ch ces avancées territoriales se joue
des frontières existantes et risque
d'entraîner l'ensemble de la région dans
un chaos total et dans une remise en
cause des équilibres issus de la
première guerre mondiale d'une zone
éminemment stratégique pour l'europe
mais aussi pour l'asie la prise de
conscience malheureusement trop récente
de ce danger a permis de réunir une
coalition dont l'objectif est clairement
d'éradiquer d'esch et nous nous en
félicitons
même si comme le constater le ministre
des affaires étrangères à l'onu
selon une formule que je fais tout à
fait mienne il y à des pays plus rapide
que d'autres à prendre leurs
responsabilités
la difficulté que ce redoutable ennemi
est asymétrique il sait se diluer pour
se reconcentrer il alterne la barbarie
la plus brutale et la subtilité du
maniement des nouvelles armes que sont
le cyber espace et la bataille de
l'opinion de l'influent ans voulait je
dire il est extrêmement mobiles se
fondent dans la population mais
disposant même temps d'armements
sophistiqués et de ressources
financières considérables
vous y faisait référence
ils n'offrent pas de prise il sait se
reconfigurer ses fragilités logistique
et de communication ne sont hélas
qu'éphémère face à cet ennemi face à ces
nouvelles structures du terrorisme
notre action doit être globale
la feuille de route de cette action a
été clairement défini par la résolution
21 70 du conseil de sécurit de sécurité
adoptée le 15 août dernier par la
conférence de paris du 15 septembre et
par la déclaration du président du
conseil de sécurité du 19 septembre
tout cela auquel s'ajoute l'appel du
gouvernement irakien constitue selon
moins bien que j'eusse préféré comme
vous une décision encore plus est
indiscutable mais constitue selon moi
une base juridique solide pour notre
intervention mais qui vite approche
globale dit aussi qu'elle s'est inscrit
dans le temps long de la diplomatie de
la politique et du développement
l'intervention militaire tardive contre
ce fléau s'est inscrite une fois de plus
dans l'urgence notre action mes chers
amis doit nous conduire à imposer notre
agenda alors que jusqu'à présent c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui impose complètement le
tempo l'un des aspects importants de
cette approche de cette approche globale
pardon qu'il faut appuyer sans réserve
et vous le faites pour la plupart et la
condamnation de des shows par les
autorités religieuses de l'islam
c'est un point évidemment fondamental et
je me félicite des prises de position
récentes en france en arabie saoudite ou
au royaume uni qui vont dans le bon sens
mais je vous le redis c'est sur le
terrain dans les mosquées lors des
prêches du vendredi au plus près des
populations concernées que ces
condamnations auront le plus d'impact et
cela reste nécessaire le président de la
république a fixé les limites à notre
action et notamment deux sur lesquels je
souhaite revenir brièvement la première
est de ne pas mettre de troupes au sol
les etats unis en dépit de l'envoi de
conseillers sont sur la même ligne nous
savons pourtant que l'éradication des
forces de des shs suppose des combats
qui seront sans doute très dur et que
l'appui et l'action aérienne aussi
puissant soit-il ne suffiront pas c'est
donc sur les forces irakiennes et kurdes
que reposera l'effort de la bataille
terrestre est ainsi que sur l'opposition
syrienne modérée quand une aide là aussi
trop tard vivent leur permettra de
redevenir et nous le souhaitons une
force qui compte
la seule évocation de cette question
montre que les conditions de la victoire
dépendront étroitement des solutions
politiques qui pourront être apportées
en irak même le remplacement du premier
ministre maliki la constitution d'un
gouvernement inclusif vont dans le bon
sens tout le monde l'a rappelé mais le
chemin est long et semé d'embûches pour
désolidariser les tribus sunnites de
dèche pour trouver un accord avec les
kurdes qui les convaincre de renoncer à
leurs tendances autonomistes voire
irrédentistes et pour traiter le cas des
cadres de l'ancien régime le soutien
aérien ne servira à rien si la
reconquête des territoires perdus n'est
pas faite concomitamment par l'armée
irakienne et si l'état irakien ne s'y
réinstalle pas c'est toute la question
de notre stratégie pour le jour d'après
là seconde limite est de ne pas
intervenir en ciel c'est aux états unis
heureusement appuyée par certains pays
qu'il aime comme de le faire et ça
vienne de ce passé encore hier le
ministre des affaires étrangères a
quasiment pas clairement posé les termes
de l'équation à résoudre le 19 septembre
à l'onu je le cite
des chats des forces importantes en
syrie il faut donc les poursuivre et
faire ce qui est nécessaire
nous allons soutenir l'opposition
modérée il y a certainement d'autres
choses à faire mais la france ne peut
pas non plus tout faire à elle seule il
est en effet évident pour tous que nous
ne pouvons traiter la question de neige
m dépendamment du théâtre syrienne tant
il est vrai que pour ce dernier la
notion de frontières n'existent pas il
ne saurait y avoir de sanctuaires
syrienne pour beige nous sommes dans le
même cas de figure que les talibans dans
les zones tribales pakistanaises
cette intervention pourrait
naturellement la délicate question du
gouvernement assad qui de manière très
fine après avoir tenu des élections afin
de se re légitimiser fait des offres de
service pour combattre le danger dont il
a encouragé l'émergence et feint d'être
informés par les états unis des frappes
sur son territoire cette question nous
renvoie au livre éclairant de pierre
grosser traiter avec le diable les vrais
enjeux de la diplomatie du 20e siècle la
même question se pose pour l'iran qui
est aussi selon moi un acteur
incontournable qu'il faut impliquer dans
la résolution du conflit directement ou
indirectement
mais d'autres intervenants ont posé
cette question enfin beaucoup ont évoqué
le rôle de la turquie qui viennent de
retrouver semble-t-il une marge de
manoeuvre après la libération de ces
otages tout cela montre l'extrême
complexité de la situation mais chacun à
sa place pour lutter contre cette menace
mortelle je voudrais terminer mon
entrain voir si mon intervention pardon
en soulignant quatre enjeux rapidement
qui constitue monsieur le ministre
autant de points de vigilance pour notre
commission que je la président ou
qu'elle soit présidée par quelqu'un
d'autre je pense que son état d'esprit
perdure heureux
la france ne peut le premier porte
pardonnez-moi sur la dispersion des
théâtres et la diversité des opex qui
pèsent sur notre outil de défense
la france ne peut évidemment pas tout je
rappelle que nos forces armées sont
engagés dans une vingtaine de pécs plus
au kosovo monsieur pour tony borgo 1 cc
on est plus engagées au kosovo en jeu je
tiens à vous le dit ça ça s'adapter un
peu dans une vingtaine d'opex neuf à
douze mille hommes ont été en moyenne
simultanément engagé en opération sur
l'ebit dernières années c'est un effort
considérable et je rends hommage une
fois de plus à nos militaires et à nos
armées notre engagement fort sur la
bande de saharienne serval puis
désormais le dispositif
régionaliser barkan est saluée de tous
mais nous savons que le travail n'est
pas fini en particulier en libye
sera notre prochain théâtre d'engagement
nous l'avons ni avec une mission dès la
fin 2012 répéter avec nos deux rapports
chevènement larcher en 2013 en sus de
libye prolifèrent un cancer terroriste
qu'il faut aussi traiter le président
hollande en a fait une priorité lors de
son discours de la conférence des
ambassadeurs
tout cela pose à l'évidence la question
de nos possibilités de notre degré
d'engagement et du partage des tâches
avec nos alliés et partenaires
le deuxième enjeu mais sert collègues
c'est notre appréciation autonome de
situation notre capacité à nous engager
en premier et notre autonomie
stratégique qui sont le socle de notre
souveraineté ils doivent selon moi être
absolument préserver le troisième enjeu
ce sont les moyennes ne nous services de
renseignement qui selon - dans votre
fille être conforté c'est vrai tant sur
le plan intérieur pour démanteler les
filières de recrutement de combattants
étrangers que pour affaiblir à
l'extérieur l'ennemi là où il se trouve
la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement
c'est unanimement prononcés monsieur le
président de la commission des lois pour
une consolidation législative du cadre
juridique des services de renseignement
il est important monsieur le ministre
que nous puissions avancer et là nous
demandons au gouvernement d'aller un
petit peu
de presser le pas
enfin les ressources de la défense
doivent être au rendez-vous à mon ami
trillard membres de la commission que
j'ai l'honneur de présider encore pour
quelques jours je voudrais dire
avec beaucoup de cordialité
attention quand on s'exprime sur le
budget de la défense et de ses contours
pensez vous toujours la question que je
me pose lorsque d'autres que la majorité
actuelle gouvernent notre pays si nous
avions été dans cette situation
aurions nous fait mieux
or aurions-nous mieux c est donc en
regardant mon ami trillard jolie demande
est ce que le fait d'avoir réussi à
obtenir la sanctuarisation de 31
milliards 4 est quelque chose que l'on
peut balayer d'un revers de main je ne
le crois pas je crois qu'on doit être
solidaire de cette décision dans le
détail comme devant la porte c'est
d'ailleurs ce que vous avez fait le plus
souvent et je vous je vous en remercie
néanmoins ces trois dernières années mes
chers collègues les opex sommes toujours
dépassé le milliard d'euros cette année
nous avons vraisemblablement déjà
franchi les 650 millions d'euros de
dépassement par rapport aux surcoûts de
budgétiser en loi de finances initiale
comptez monsieur le ministre sur la
vigilance de notre commission pour
s'assurer de la mise en oeuvre de la
mutualisation interministérielle
des surcoûts tenons budgétisé ou année
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre le
dialogue dont je ne doute pas qu'il est
tonique entre le ministère de la défense
et bercy sur ce point pouvez vous nous
donner des assurances se pose aussi
pardon de cette incongruité la question
des ressources exceptionnelles et de
leurs éventuels substitution par
d'autres ressources
des solutions doivent impérativement
être trouvé je ne vous questionner pas
je vous renouvelle tout notre soutien
pour que nous puissions aboutir
monsieur le ministre
vous l'avez compris vous pouvez compter
sur notre soutien total
vous avez notre confiance pour la
conduite des opérations mais et c'est le
rôle de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense du sénat
cette confiance s'accompagnera toujours
aussi d'une réelle vigilance qui je
pense vous servira dans votre action et
ne se relâchera pas je vous remercie
en réponse et aux orateurs la parole et
à monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
j'aurais d'abord remercier votre haute
assemblée pour la qualité des débats la
qualité des interventions la précision
des questions et
la tonalité générale de ce que nous
venons de vivre
je voudrais reprendre volontiers me
sénateurs triaire lorsqu'il l'a dit la
première réponse aux menaces c'est
l'unité nationale et votre soutien très
large que j'ai pu constater est
indispensable à nos armées est
indispensable à la sécurité de la nation
je suis très heureux de le constater à
cette heure grave il nous faut à la fois
l'unité et la détermination
je voudrais vous dire aussi en
commençant à propos qui sera assez bref
que des dépêches d'agencé nous indique
vidéo à l'appui
la probable décapitation de
notre compatriote hervé gourdel
nous sommes en train de faire les
vérifications
avant d'affirmer quoi que ce soit mais
tout cela montre bien la barbarie à
laquelle nous avons à faire
à ce propos
je voudrais
vous dire que ma ma préoccupation
principale
de ministre de la défense c'est le
risque de connexion des différents
théâtres et des différents espaces où se
manifestent de terrorisme et à propos de
l'algérie
je voudrais dire ici que le groupe qui
est en situation potentielle d'avoir
assassiné hervé gourdel s'appelle le
groupe des soldats du calife en terre
d'algérie
il est dirigé par
gouri abdelmalek
qui est
le produit du gspc qui a meurtri
l'algérie pendant de nombreuses années
et il est en même temps par son histoire
l'adjoint de l' émir droukdal
émir d'al qaïda même si ce groupe
nouveau là vient de rejoindre les tâches
parce que sans doute plus attractif et
parce que et pour cette raison il veut
montrer la force de son allégeance en
provoquant des cas des captures de nos
compatriotes et éventuellement en les
mettant leur menace à exécution
les métros galles c'est celui qui
organisait les groupes d'al qaïda au
mali au maghreb islamique au nord-mali
qui est par ailleurs réfugiés au sud
libye et il ya là des signes par rapport
à la menace globale le président carrère
faisait allusion tout à l'heure mais
d'autres intervenants aussi à cette
menace globale par cet exemple là on
voit bien les risques que représentent
dans la période qui vient cette cette
menace globale je voudrais en même temps
vous faire observer que au moment où
le al bagdadi proclamait le califat dans
la partie irak syrie
aboubakar chez cos qui est le leader de
boko haram proclamait le califat dans
cette partie de l'afrique et voilà
comment progressivement des liens des
connexions se font et il était essentiel
que nous puissions réagir en intervenant